why did you get banned on
Instagram actually to to be fair I don't
know fully but what from what I did some
digging and I found out there was a um
only fans content creator who felt like
I was pushing a narrative that goes
against sex work pornography and only
fans and so she pulled some strings
managed to get it banned I also pulled
some strings managed to get back on but
I'm sure with my big mouth I'll get
myself in trouble soon so I'm going to
make a vow and I'm glad you're here to
witness it that I'm going to try and
stay out of trouble because I don't want
to lose my Instagram it's actually a
really great platform okay well we'll
we'll see we'll see how you get on after
today so one of the things I've noticed
recently is this sort of widespread
belief that love is it's toxic why do
you think these sort of modern
representations of female stories are so
devoid of love you know looking at the
Barbie movie there's these previews of
the Snow White movie coming up Rachel
Ziggler Zigler doesn't really look like
she's Pro love what do you think is
going on well I think the debise of
marriage and long-term relationships
what that means is with relationships a
bit like when you watch a movie and the
whole movie can be great but if the
ending is [__] we'll say movies are [__]
that movie was awful similarly if the
ending is fantastic you'll say that
whole movie was great usually the people
pushing this narrative have just come
out of a negative relationship so they
Define the entire course of love and the
entire course of relationships by their
particular ending and if the ending was
terrible love is terrible and they label
it like that and they also like to run
with a narrative that my ex is a
narcissist is their favorite phrase on
the planet at the moment what that does
is kind of devoid us of the
responsibility in causing that toxicity
blame it on someone else and then blame
love as a separate entity as a cause for
our pain when really it's our behaviors
so the love isn't toxic it's how we
behave in love and how we behave when
vulnerable that creates toxicity but
it's easier to just say that love is
this really dangerous emotion and we
should avoid it at all cost and always
keep our armor up just in case love
comes at us and kills us when really
it's our poor decision- making or our
behaviors that cause love to be toxic
yeah I it's strange to me that it
appears to be like a top- down narrative
as well it's not just individuals
rejecting love it's also in movies it's
in culture as well yeah and I I do I do
think there is you know there is a lot
to be gained from convincing people that
love is toxic and you don't need it
because Independence breeds more
customers whether it's on social media
media whether it's on porn sites whether
it's on cosmetic surgery Independence
creates customers so I think that it
makes total sense from a marketing
perspective to Just Breathe the idea
that love is no longer necessary I saw a
lot of interviews from the star of Snow
White where she was almost making Digs
at what is actually quite a sweet fairy
tale but trying to make it into digs and
I just thought um I'm guessing The
Narrative of seeing love is weak is
being propagated in the culture today I
don't know yeah there's a a quote from
that
interview she's not going to be saved by
the prince she's not going to be
dreaming about true love she's dreaming
about becoming the leader she knows she
can be the prince in the original movie
stalked
her what why would you sign up to a film
if that's what you believe was the
message behind it I'm guessing because
here's what they're taking is I'm not
saying Disney movies were great for our
perception of love either but the idea
of mocking connection and mocking and
let's say for example somebody does save
you and you're in a bad position but
they do save you why is that so negative
if somebody's going through something
and you find a partner and they help you
heal and you both help each other heal
why is that a negative thing I mean I I
I maybe I've got it wrong but the the
narrative I'm getting is it's almost
seen as embarrassing to fall in love
when really it's an essential component
of um of our life we all need it it
seems to me the advice for men suggests
that Falling in Love Makes You
irrational and weak and for women it
makes you subservient and dependent and
it's almost the opposite of what both
sexes want to have right there's a trend
of wanting women to have their own
independence at the moment like more
power to them and there's a trend of
wanting men to be able to stand up for
themselves more and love is being
positioned as the antithesis of the
thing that you're trying to get yeah
well love is seen as suffering and
here's the thing there's a big
difference between U pain and suffering
like pain is just things that happen in
our life like let's say the person you
love passes away or you have you can't
have a baby that that's pain uh but
suffering is the emotional consequences
of our poor decision- making now if you
feel like love is suffering for you have
a look at your decision- making if
you're becoming weak but if you Choose
Wisely be you won't see it as being weak
you'll see it as being a com compatible
and you see it as being uh compromising
but if and if you're becoming
subservient if you choose the right
person you won't see it as a form of
abuse but if you're making poor
decisions of course love is going to be
a form of suffering but suffering is a
reminder that you made wrong choices
yeah I was watching this baggage claim
video earlier on she's great and she
talks about this sort of common
anti-love Trend among she calls it
feminists uh a a general disinterest in
emotional connection with men this is
this sort of plague that she thinks
going on at the moment um I agree and I
think it's found um just to kind of even
out the playing field it's also found
amongst the red peel men and um like we
spoke about before when you feel like
you can't access something the best and
quickest way to defend your ego is to
pretend you don't want it so to when you
feel like you're not worthy of love and
which I really think is a a
manifestation of low self-esteem when
you feel like you're not worthy of love
the quickest and easiest way to feel
Worthy is to pretend love is terrible
pretend love is toxic and I see this a
lot in red pill men and really high like
proud feminist both cohorts tend to be
people who personally probably believe
that they're not desirable to the
opposite gender so the only way to get
rid of that feeling of like being
undesired is to pretend you don't desire
the opposite gender so I see it both and
they're almost a perfect match for each
other that bluehead you know feminist
and that red pill guy they're almost a
perfect match because they both almost
have the same pathologies when it comes
to their understanding of love so they
they should get together yeah that would
be a very interesting relationship to
observe yeah I um there's this idea
called the inner Citadel that people
Retreat into if you can't get what you
want you must teach yourself to want
what you can get right and that's kind
of what you're describing you know if I
tell myself that uh all women are awful
then it doesn't force me to try and get
into a relationship and therefore I
don't need to feel the pain of
heartbreak if I tell myself that jobs
are completely pointless then I can sit
in unemployment and not be concerned
about not making progress toward my
goals exactly but the problem with that
is it prevents you from fulfilling your
potential in life human beings are
designed with the potential to love and
nurture one another and whenever we cap
our potential whether that's through
like we cap our potential physically
emotionally psychologically anything
that involves capping our potential will
lead to a slow and steady depression
that will signal to yourself that you're
not fulfilling your potential and it
will come out and manifest as a form of
depression so when you kind of ward off
love you're warding off your own full
potential and therefore you will see an
increase in your depression and anxiety
they even find studies where women when
um they hold their partner's hand during
labor they experience less pain that's
how much we're designed to be in love
it's actually a a pain relief it's an
anti- anxiety they found loads of
studies where they see uh people that
you know sleep with lots of people in a
communion they sleep better they don't
have any like micro Awakenings in the
night so we're our body craves it
whether you psychologically convinced
yourself you don't want it your body
will still speak to you and tell you
that you need it so unfortunately it
doesn't work the micro Awakenings thing
is really interesting I remember
learning it from Johan Hari that it's
basically a um it's like a measure of
comfort that people have in safety right
so um 15,000 years ago you have gone out
hunting and you decide to sleep in a
cave that is away from where you usually
would it's adaptive for you as this
nomadic person away from home to not go
into quite as deep sleep because you
can't be quite as assured that this
particular location is safe it's one of
the reasons why people get such bad
nights sleep in hotels yeah because even
if the room is quiet and it's dark and
there's no LED blinking and room service
doesn't come and accidentally knock on
your door it's still not your house and
we have this inbuilt micro Awakening
where you just come back up the
threshold of Consciousness and then dip
back in again yeah two things that are
interesting if you have the sound of a
crackling fire or the sound of snoring
dogs both of those reduce micro
Awakenings oh wow fire would have scared
away predators and the dogs would have
been an early warning system oh amazing
so that well I I I read the same thing
with J Harry's book which is fantastic
um was it lost connections is that the
right one and yeah it says the same
thing evolutionary wise were designed to
sleep with others because that creates a
sense of um safety against predators so
when people come to me and they have
insomnia they have depression the first
thing I ask is what are your connections
like what is your relationships like
with other people and they convince
themselves they don't want a
relationship but I do understand there's
a part of me and I've spoken about this
a little bit with when I was speaking to
my clients I kind of I can understand
why the lazy kind of man that feels
undesirable is avoiding relationships
because there's a lot of effort for very
little return When the alternative is I
can either watch pornography or I can
hire an escort again little effort and a
maximum return so I get from a logical
point of view if I'm going to spend
hundreds of pounds on a date and she
might not even sleep with me I can spend
half of that on an escort she definitely
will but the goal of life is not to get
sex it's to get connection and that's
what they're trying to skip
unfortunately have you reflected on the
rise of escorts and sex work I think
it's pretty fascinating to look at the
psychology of the women who do it and
the men who pay for it yeah well the
women who do usually and I think it's
probably less now but there's a a big
history of childood sexual abuse and the
reason why child abuse often then
becomes monetized sex work is because
when we are violated as a child men or
women when we when something is violated
from us the only way your ego kind of
makes sense of what happens to you is to
minimize the importance and significance
of what was stolen from you so if I was
abused sexually if I then minimize the
importance of sex and then take some
control by monetizing it and saying I'm
now in control of my body I'm either
going to be hyper promiscuous or I'm
going to monetize it what it does is
minimizes the significance of sex and
therefore I don't have to deal with the
trauma I experienced I now see sex as
just an activity and therefore if I was
abused it's not that serious and so the
psychology of them is usually coming
from a broken place and also the other
thing that they struggle with is knowing
what loyalty looks like in a
relationship they don't see it as an
essential component because they've
monetized sex and um taken away the
emotion em element to it so it becomes
very difficult for them to be sexually
loyal to their partner it's almost like
they see sex as a bit as an activity and
if they do it with somebody else why
would that bother you they don't
understand the process so they end up
being quite emotionally disconnected
very transactional with their partners
and the relationships become the the
relationships don't really last very
long unfortunately they're a void of
emotions and then it translates into
their parenting as well what about the
psychology of the men who pay for it um
the psychology of the man that actually
goes towards it is usually he somebody
who's highly avoidant to begin with
there was some emotional disconnect in
their parents in their household so when
you want to CAU a beautiful woman in the
real world she requires some emotional
connection first and foremost or at
least at some point now if you've if you
find it hard to experience emotional
connection and you have the money to go
from pornography to escorts you skip the
emotional component and go straight to
escorts it basically escorts are porn
addicts with
money yeah essentially that is for them
and that low self-esteem that intense
low self-esteem um with the men that pay
for escorts means that they don't
believe they can access a woman of that
caliber in real life so let me at least
pay in for it and therefore I don't have
to experience rejection the reason why
emotional kind of Disconnect is so
important for the customer is a man that
understands emotional intelligence and
understands a woman's emotions wouldn't
feel comfortable having sex with a woman
he knows doesn't want to be there a guy
that normally has emotional intelligence
will think oh God she's probably not
enjoying this and oh God what trauma led
her to get here I don't want to have sex
with somebody who doesn't want to have
sex with me but the man who skipped that
emotional intelligence and just wants
pleasure will not even think about the
emotional trauma that got her to this
position and just think as long as she
pleases me I don't really care what it
took to get her here so that emotional
disconnect in both of them which is why
they often fall in love with each other
fall in love yeah they often do end up
together and this is what I really hate
about the narrative that they tell you
that on these red pill podcasts that men
want virgins men want good girls the
amount of successful men that fall in
love with the escorts is because they
allow him to not emotionally connect but
then still boost his ego which is what
his dream come true whereas another
woman requires that emotional connection
before she can boost your ego so the
escort is just providing him with an ego
boost with bearing in mind his emotional
disabilities that's interesting I
noticed is it can I ask is it big in in
America as well cuz it's huge where I
live I haven't seen it I mean Dubai I
think is a a very particular uh petri
dish of of like unique dating maybe
Miami I mean in fact I would almost be
certain withi L is London is getting
there as well it's getting just as
rampant in London as well I'm noticing
that you were in all of these locations
if you moved to Miami too you would be
the color denominator I'm the problem
maybe I bring I bring the heat so I
noticed when I was at Uni and I was
running a lot of nightclubs and we would
go the only place that's open after 3 in
the morning at the strip clubs right so
we would go to the strip clubs and we
would like we know all of the girls cuz
most of the girls would come out to one
of our events on an evening time or
whatever and I noticed a lot of the
girls were
struggling they would struggle to see
men as like not genuine humans but
because their job required them to see
man as resources to be extracted from
like anyone that's ever been to a proper
workingclass strip club right there's
still you know like girls in there I'm
not derating the quality of the women
I'm talking about the kind of culture
that comes
through they are [__] ruthless with
how they take money from men like
they're sitting on their lap they it's
almost like a sales funnel they
understand the tricks that they can use
to get a man to go for a dance to get a
man to stay with you and so on and so
forth they entered the game like the
arena of play is and if they've had too
much to drink or they've done whatever
like probably should G to the strip club
with your credit card if that's the case
but what happened on the other side of
that I noticed that a lot of the girls
struggled to make an emotional
connection with guys in their personal
life and I think that trying to separate
out this is someone that I'm supposed to
have a genuine connection with and this
is someone that I'm supposed to have a
transactional connection with these two
it doesn't surprise me that you can't
that these are going to bleed into each
other in the same has to be true with
only fans um what happens with only fans
and strippers and sex workers in general
the pool of women that they're left with
with are men they don't respect the
reality is women respect men with
masculinity Alpha protectiveness um
providing Etc now when you go into sex
work you are left with firstly your
customers are incredibly low self-esteem
incredibly naive to even believe that
you're going to be loyal to them and
even if he's not your customer and he's
your boyfriend but he accepts your sex
work a part of you doesn't see him as
powerful and a provider and doesn't see
him as protective because if he was
truly protective he wouldn't be with you
if it was a man that genuinely was an
alpha man and wanted a good woman he
wouldn't be with you so the type of men
they truly respect wouldn't be with them
so the only men they can they they
definitely can't fall in love with the
guy that is the you know giving them
money the closest thing they get to that
is the pimp that's taking money from
them because at least then they kind of
respect the fact that he he's using her
in a way but to be manipulated by her
she feels more powerful than him and
therefore can't respect him I wonder how
many girls in strip clubs get into
relationships with the bouncers and the
door staff and the manager and stuff
like that they end up more they're just
more likely to be with a man that they
provide for than a one that provides for
them because a man that provides for a
stripper there's a stupidity in that
because you know this woman's
transactional and yet you're giving her
money she can't respect you but the man
she has to pay for whether he's like a
bouncer that's on half her wage or he's
just a personal trainer that she has to
cover the rent for she's more likely to
fall in love with him because at least
he's not stupid enough to financially
invest in me and a part of her
unconsciously respects him more than the
CEO that's going to buy you a house and
a Range Rover CU she's like you're so
stupid what have you come to reflect on
about the psychology of [__] shaming um
it's a way of validating poor decision-
making so when we use the word you're
[__] shaming what we're really saying is
stop pointing out the flaws in my flawed
Behavior essentially we need a society
filled with guilt shame and regret we
need to be aware Ware of these emotions
if we remove shame from our society and
we call it fat shaming [__] shaming
essentially we find a way of normalizing
what is abnormal behavior and when we do
that we then become Reckless we need
guilt shame and regret to help direct us
into making proper decision- making
responsible decision making healthy
decision- making so whenever you hear
the word that's fat shaming and that
[__] shaming if the word before it is
negative then the actual the concept is
broken we'll get back to talking to sju
in one minute but first I need to tell
you about element stop having coffee
first thing in the morning your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't even active for the first 90
minutes of the day but your adrenal
system is and salt acts on your adrenal
system elements contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium and potassium and magnesium that
plays a critical role in reducing muscle
cramps and fatigue whilst optimizing
brain health and regulating your
appetite they are the exclusive
hydration partner to team us us a
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
elite athletes around the world best of
all they have a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it and try
it all and if you do not like it for any
reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you love it head to the link in the
description below or go to drink LM
nt.com slod wisdom to get a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box that's drink LM nt.com /
modern wisdom well what would you say to
the people who say we've had a sexual
Revolution Sadia we don't need like
girls can sleep with guys as much as
they want to this is the new world get
up to date now it's
2023 why should it be the case that that
is negative shameful guilt riddled
Behavior because you're the one saying
that men are trash and yet you're
sleeping with them all day every day
you're the it's the women that sleep
around the most that will say men are
trash the women in healthy relationships
are not usually the ones saying that so
if this formula is working why are you
allowing trash to enter your
vagina I had an idea I had a theory
about the game theory of [__] shaming
and the game theory of simp shaming as
well I want to teach you about okay
so as far as I can see more [__] shaming
comes from women than it does from men
right which might be on the surface
surprising but a bit more inspection it
makes sense yeah the reason that more
[__] shaming comes from women than do
from men is because women are invested
in other women not lowering the price of
sex too low yeah men would happily have
the price of sex be zero right if you
are prepared to give [__] on the
third day but I want to wait until the
fifth date I'm also a girl and I want to
wait until the fifth date it's in my
interests to raise the price of sex
right by shaming anybody who is more
sexually promiscuous than I am so the
problem that women are trying to combat
is women who give sex without loyalty or
resources right they want to raise the
the amount of loyalty and resources that
other women use before they will give
away sexual access now what I realized I
think is true men simp shame for the
exact same reason in the opposite
direction so women are concerned about
sex without resources men are concerned
with resources without sex right so what
a simp is fundamentally doing is saying
I will give away one of the the few
things that men are supposed to hold in
the highest value which is their ability
to provide and I will give you that in
return for nothing yeah right or in
return for some messages through a
platform or perhaps just financially
dominated or sugar babying your way
through college or or traveling or
whatever it is that you want to do so I
feel like the energy is very similar oh
yeah between these two simp shaming and
[__] shaming both of them are trying to
ensure that competitors of the same sex
don't give away the most valuable
resource which they don't want to have
the price of derogated too low what do
you think absolutely it's a form of in
seexual selection which in evolutionary
psychology just simply means your
competition within your sex now the
quickest and easiest way for women to
kind of beat the competition is verbal
aggression and one of the things that
[__] shaming does is firstly of course
like you mentioned it reduces the value
of sex so you're competing with people
who give it for free but in addition by
[__] shaming is our way of unconsciously
trying to put other men off that woman
now people only [__] shame attractive
women you don't see PE there are many
unattractive women who are also sleeping
with lots and lots of men but what
happens with women they only feel the
need to shame when the person is a
threat in any way shape or form you will
not see unattractive women get as many
trolls as attractive women online and
you will not get unattracted women who
sleep around get as many [__] shaming
comments as sex because they scen as
less of a threat they're not a threat so
essentially what intr seexual selection
does is it makes women use verbal
aggression against one another but only
if she's a threat if she's not a form of
threat we actually turn it into praise
because then it works to actually be
friends with women because you can share
breastfeeding child wearing in
evolutionary terms Al parenting yeah but
if she is any form of threat she can
potentially take your partner and take
your resources so whenever women are
[__] shaming and stuff they usually
focus on the women that they think that
their partner would find attractive so
they might not [__] shame let's say for
example it's an English Manch they might
not [__] shame the workers in Thailand
and stuff like that but they would [__]
shame the local only fan scales because
it's more of a threat so essentially we
um verbally attack those that we see as
a biggest threat and that will reduce
the ability of us to secure resources
from a man yeah very interesting yeah
and a sad thing as well because I get a
lot of hate from women particularly from
women saying that I don't side with
women enough and I always just say you
have no idea what it's like to be around
women like I well maybe they do but for
me personally I've only ever ever
experienced negativity from women
especially in the workplace so it's hard
for me to really be like women are
amazing women empowerment women women
women when we I know from my personal
experience we don't support each other
at all yeah that's it's a a ruthless
sort of realization I had Joyce bennon
on uh I've had Christina duranti on I've
had Dr Sarah hillan you know a lot of
evolutionary psychology researchers who
are looking at intersexual competition
Candice Blake
and one of the things that Joyce looked
at was the body language of female
basketball
teams she found that male opponents
showed more physical affection to each
other than female compatriots so men on
opposite teams of a basketball court
still nicer to each other were more like
physically affectionate than girls that
were on the same team and I think that
there's a lot of stuff going on with
hierarchy how that works it's the reason
whys don't their achievements
academically if they know that other
people are going to out because stepping
outside of that hierarchy is something
that's a little bit dangerous and that's
kind of Ruthless right like it should be
the case as a girl that if you succeed
and do something well that you should be
able to like be proud about it and you
should be able to Proclaim it and other
people should say yeah [__] you did good
well done and one of the disadvantages
men are ruthless to each other in very
specific ways but so are women yeah it
was and and the thing is with men they
would hunt and gather tribes so it makes
sense for them to have camaraderie and
be part of a group for women we wouldn't
necessarily use each other to go hunt we
would only feel secure once we've
secured the person that gives us
resources so that's why married women
tend to be who are happily in
relationships tend to be less verbally
hostile to ones that are single so
single women together are tend to be
more verbally hostile to one another
than when those that are happily spoken
for because they're no longer in that
competition zone so unfortunately the
reality of um female and female
empowerment it only only works if you're
not threatened by each other the moment
there's a form of threat they become
very hostile and very aggressive and so
it's very difficult to have a platform
where you're trying to just educate
people about human nature as a woman
because you'll get very much a lot of
hatred from other women so it's not the
easiest what's your what are your
qualifications I'm a psychologist so
what I did is I did a psychology degree
then I followed by Masters then I
actually just went into teaching so I
did went into teaching but then I did
Psych psychodynamic diploma so okay is
Psych is psychologist not like a
protected term do you not need have a
doctorate or something for that you do
if you're a research psychologist and if
you're going to go into like Clinical
Psychology okay yeah I am so I haven't
done a doctorate I would like to but it
takes a long time got you okay talk to
me about the problem with nice guys then
talking about simps essentially what
nice guys do is what they suffer with is
not that they're too nice or anything
it's just that they have incredibly weak
boundaries when it comes to women they
simply and not actually not just women
it could be anybody what they do is they
lack a lot of masculinity and what they
do is they blame the fact that they're
so nice as to why they can't get women
but it's not about being nice it's about
a lack of masculinity and one of the
best ways to establish masculinity is
placing boundaries particularly with
women when you don't like a behavior you
don't roll over and allow it to continue
and then give her more in order for you
to get her you set a boundary and you
have a willingness to walk away nice
guys what happens is they don't like to
exert their boundaries and they don't
have a willingness to walk away so what
ends up happening is nice nature becomes
a reason for resentment because women
don't like it they actually feel angry
when you're too nice to them because
then they don't feel protected they feel
like you're weak if you let a woman make
all the decisions for you she'll slowly
start to hate you because she'll feel
like she has to raise you and she'll
lose respect for you so you're better
what we truly want is not a man that
just is like chaotic we just want a man
who we can trust makes good decisions
he's not the nice guy he's the one that
we'll submit to but the one that doesn't
trust his own decision- making and we
have to do it and he comes across as
being eyes essentially he seen as weak
yeah overly pliable yeah is the term
that I think about it's hard could you
like how do you as a man make sure that
you're nice and not weak like it must be
difficult because in this day and age if
you try and be like a bit more assertive
that I'm guessing it gets a lot of push
back it's it's hard for a man how I
don't know I think he'd be surprised I
think
that you
know the line of acceptable behavior is
way wider than most people think right
you know you can be assertive in
a powerful reassuring way without being
a tyrant it's pretty it's pretty easy to
achieve right I I I don't think that
it's that hard but I also understand
that a lot of people don't have a
massive amount of firsthand experience
yeah they're spending all of their time
learning about things through the
internet they don't actually have the
you need to be skillful and Nimble right
to be able flirting and dealing with
with even the same sex LEL and the
opposite sex is like a delicate balance
right it's a bit of a dance it's a bit
of teasing is it too far is it too much
like you
know it's it requires experience and
most people don't have the opportunity
to develop that and it's really easy to
have the willingness to walk away when
you're somebody that has a lot of
Alternatives and it doesn't just mean
other women it could be a lifestyle that
is alternative to being settled down but
when you're somebody that doesn't have
many Alternatives the willingness to
walk away decreases so I do understand
it's very difficult for men to have that
but without the willingness to walk away
she'll look for a man that does have the
willingness to walk away she'll look for
a man that does have boundaries because
we need them as women it's strange and I
also understand that it must be ruthless
to think oh well I would really like a
nice guy maybe your last relationship is
with some dude that was in very avoidant
uh like masculine in a non supporting
way and you think okay well I I'll go
for a nice guy I'll go for a guy that's
a bit more pliable and a lot more
agreeable and then if what you're saying
is true and you end up resenting them
you go that that wasn't what I wanted
either so it must be difficult it must
be difficult for essentially what we
truly want is a man whose decision
making on his own is one that we can
naturally submit to what I mean by that
is if I have to tell you to do this that
and the other and you listen to me I
don't respect you anymore because if I
had to tell you and you listen to me and
I'm better than you at making decisions
I'm more powerful than you I don't feel
protected you simply have to be a man
that could literally take a girl by a
hand and lead her into whatever
lifestyle you is but she feels safe in
that knowledge but if you're the typee
of guy who's like second guessing
himself if you're second guessing
yourself and then submitting to me it's
a we automatically don't find that
attractive we that can't be the same for
every girl though right there must be a
spectrum of women it it works well for
women who are planning to manipulate you
so the women that are planning to
manipulate and planning to use a man
they love this guy without boundaries
the one that's the girl that genuinely
wants to have a connection with you
build a family with you have a network
with you she actually want wants you to
have a backbone and wants you to have an
opinion the one that's planning to not
stick around too long the one that's
planning to be with keep in touch with
another guy the guy a girl that wants an
alimony as soon as the kids arrive
that's the one that wants you to be this
people pleaser bend over backwards do
everything I say yeah what about people
Pleasers more generally on the girl side
and on the guy side well I guess they
would be a similar match but what I
happen with with two people Pleasers
like where the woman is just a nice girl
and the guys is are just a nice guy they
don't create an authentic connection cuz
neither of them are giving each other
the glue or the vulnerability to attach
one saying I'll just do what you want
the other one okay I'll just do what you
want we don't know each other we're just
a comfort blanket but one of them at
least has to be a bit dis disagreeable
to create that connection give you that
kind of glue to attach to so
unfortunately two people PES don't
usually end up together did you watch
succession no I didn't okay so it's
pretty cool it's this series on HBO and
I think it's really early on maybe the
one of the first few episodes in the
first season and this tyrannical father
is pointing at his own only daughter
who's just got married to a guy who's
very pliable at least for the first few
seasons unbelievably pliable right um he
is a bit of a social climber the
potential future husband bit of a social
climber he kind of wants to be a part of
the crew so to speak uh and he says the
dad is just [__] going around the
room like this is something I don't like
about you and this is something I don't
like about you he points at sh of the
daughter and he says you married a man
that's beneath you because you're
terrified of being betrayed a [__]
painful but in that moment I saw
something that's very true you know the
people that are scared of losing their
partner a lot of the time will date down
aggressively date down because they know
that they're so far ahead of what that
partner would typically be in a
relationship with with shiv it's largely
resources and money and access which is
kind of strange because the Dynamics
flipped typically from the way it would
be but um yeah that just that really
it's like one of the most brutal insults
like it insults both of them at the same
time with one thing you married a man
that's beneath you because you're
terrified of being betrayed and it's
very true a lot of women and men um use
that strategy but the problem is you
almost guarantee the divorce if I marry
someone beneath me to prevent him
cheating on me that doesn't change the
other aspect that is required for a
healthy relationship which is bringing
equal value to each other's life and
when one feels like they are married Ben
below it it doesn't work out either the
true connection comes when you both
bring equal value and you don't and you
choose to be with each other rather than
you know he can't do any better or she
can't do any better eventually that
catches up because a person with low
self-esteem who feels like they've you
know been punching eventually starts to
get so much low self-esteem that they
might seek external validation so they
might be more likely to cheat or more
likely to dis uh to betray you because
at some point they can feel that you
know they know that you know that you're
above them and that low self-esteem can
create a desire to connect outside so
unfortunately there isn't really a cure
to that other than true connection but
one thing I would say about people
pleasing they say that it's linked to an
absent father they say that people what
has having a um a father figure does is
that rough and tumble kind of play and
that harsh criticism gets you in the
habit of speaking truth even if it's not
the nicest thing to do whereas the
absence of that can actually make you
think that you're going to offend
because it's easy to offend Mom it's
harder to offend dad so when you get
used to that rough and tumble kind of
verbal um ations with fathers It
prepares you for the real world of where
you are less sensitive and more likely
to be truthful rather than people
pleasing what about the opposite then
what about treat them mean keep them
Keen as opposed to people pleasing um
again another tactic um that's very much
advocated in current dating but is again
counterproductive because the moment you
treat people mean you filter out healthy
people healthy people don't stick around
to be treated badly that doesn't go in
line with their template of
relationships healthy people have a
template of relationship that requires
mutual respect now when they're with
somebody who treats them mean they
filter themselves out they understand
they might work on it for a little bit
but they recognize where they're not
welcome um when you're treating them
mean keeping them Keem you're attaching
to somebody that has incredibly low
self-esteem who expects to be treated
like this who will then when you start
when you stop playing that game and
actually want to commit to that person
or particularly that girl she'll become
volatile she'll self-sabotage because
she's so used to being treated mean
commit doesn't actually feel good it
feels unfamiliar so she'll recreate some
chaos in order to create the separation
because treating the mean keeping them
ke doesn't work
unfortunately do you think men and women
can be friends yes I do do you think
they can be friends I've seen it go both
ways uhuh more times than not it seems
to mess up but I it's it's not
impossible I've got a number of friends
who have managed to do that totally
platonically do you have female friends
do I have fale friends I do I do have
some yeah but they're mostly kind of
from the industry from podcasting uh uh
Michaela Peterson's probably one of my
closest friends on the planet great
um a yeah so it's some it's I think it's
tough I think it's tough what do you
think makes it tough about having F Well
just that the line between what you have
and what you're familiar with when it
comes to guys and
girls and the line of romantic Des
desability is pretty fine and it only
needs to be confused by one party for
the relation for the Friendship to break
down right it doesn't need both people
to want it to happen if both people want
it to happen the friendship turns into a
relationship if one person wants it to
happen the friendship's no longer a
friendship you right so just you've got
a lot of different ways and then let's
forget that let's say that one of either
people gets into a relationship with
someone that isn't in the Friendship
then there's like two more people that
could have a problem you can't see that
that person anymore I don't like it when
you go around her house I don't like it
when you spend time with him so there's
so many different ways that this can go
wrong I understand and one thing I would
like to point out about that because men
can never understand why females can
have male friends and but we tend to
believe that we can have male friends
and the reason why we kind of think like
this is because we would rather have
somebody a a friend who secretly loves
us than a female friend that secretly
hates us and you guys don't have to
experience that usually when men don't
like each other they separate from each
other women when they don't like each
other they'll make reservations together
and they'll still go on holidays
together and they'll still keep in each
other's lives so when We crave male
friendships it's because you don't know
the pain well not necessarily pain that
sounds a bit exaggerated but the
difficulty in finding good female
friendships they're not as easy for us
where men if they play a sport together
they can pretty much be friends for us
you can do everything right with a
female friendship all it takes is you
know a birthday gone wrong or a
boyfriend that they don't like or or a
boyfriend that they both like um and the
entire friendship is destroyed and
there's a safety in a male friendship
that we can't find in female friendships
because it's very difficult to find
women that are totally not threatened by
you in any way shape or from by other
women and that's even when you're I'm
not saying just when you're attractive
even when you're less attractive you
still have friends similar level of
attractiveness so there is a form of
threat even there uh so that's the first
thing I think women can why women can
have better friendships with men the
other thing is I just think if you are a
woman or a man of value beyond your
sexual kind of um proudness if you got
something other to offer isn't it
natural that men women old young
everybody's going to gravitate towards
you and want to be around you I just
think it's natural it's a natural
consequence of being a valuable person
is that people gravitate towards you in
the male and female form they will
gravitate towards you so to kind of have
an arbitrary role that you can't have
male and can't have female it would only
work if your personality is limited if
you have a limited personality if I'm a
girl that only talks about hair and
makeup of course I can only have female
friends but if I'm a woman that can have
a lot of different types of
conversations it's natural to be able to
connect with different type of people
there's two things that makes me think
about first I had the director of
relationship science from hinge Logan
URI on the show
about a year and a half ago uh and she
taught me about um people confused spark
in the beginning of a relationship for
something special without realizing that
some people are just Sparky to everyone
yes and that was a really interesting
insight and it's kind of like what
you're talking about here right that if
you're somebody that's interesting and
trustworthy and of high value in the
world people are just going to gravitate
toward you because you're a nice person
to know you're useful you're cool you're
fun to be around you're interesting
right so there are certain people who
just suck others in right now the second
thing have you heard of the
overperception and under perception bias
of Attraction so this is really
interesting it's out of evolutionary
psychology
so men
over perceive the level of attraction
that they believe women have toward them
and women under perceive the level of
attraction that men have toward them
it's to referred to as a failure of
cross- seex mind reading and this shows
up very reliably in the data David bus
put this out in bad men or Men Behaving
Badly depending on which country you're
in this is why a boss or a co-worker
will maybe make an ungainly move apart
from like the creeps like Harvey
Weinstein like that make anain move
because they will believe that oh yeah
you know her eyes always linger on me
she always makes it to the water cooler
at the same time that I do she's always
in the the printing her stuff in the
cupboard the same time that I do as well
maybe I should try and ask her out
yeah it is much more useful for men to
have a smoke alarm that goes off a lot
and is wrong a lot but is right every so
often because the price of missing a
potential signal is really high and the
cost of noticing a signal that wasn't
there is essentially zero right the
reverse for women in speed dating they
did this they put men and women down at
a speed dating event asked both of them
how attracted were you to the other one
women regularly rated that they were way
less attracted to the man than the man
thought and the reverse
Tru this is the failure of cross- seex
mind reading and it explains so much
about the world that men and women
inhabit because we don't inhabit the
same world I don't see my interaction
with you the same way that you see your
interaction with me and this reliably
smeared across an entire population is
why men and women don't understand each
other because we do not have the same
brains and we don't see the world in the
same way you know but when I do deal
with uh clients who are you know men who
are very lonely and um who struggle with
female connection I do ask them do you
have any female friends and the answer
is invariably no and I always say that
you need them and they're like no we
shouldn't be friends men and women can't
be friends and I said but they training
ground for women in the real world
because when you have female friends
they teach you what things upset women
what things up make them happy what they
mean by when they text slowly when they
text fast when they don't text at all
they teach you so much that you can't
learn from women directly because when a
woman is in love with a man she can't
help but play stupid games because it's
part of a protection strategy so what
she'll do is say she's done when she's
not done or say she doesn't want to
sleep with you and she doesn't want to
sleep with you she'll say the opposite
of what she truly means but having
female friends helps you understand this
human ology behind a woman in a way that
experience direct experience with them
won't so that's why I actually say
because so many of my male friends would
be like this girl just did that I'm like
oh that means she wants you to do you
translate you can see the code not the
matx the code because we speak in code
yeah well outside Destiny who you should
speak to at some point because I think
you guys who I think is great by the way
Destin's fascinating dude I think is
fantastic very very very very big fan of
Destiny he said that someone asked him
what the best piece of dating advice he
is he could give to guys and he says
during High School have lots of female
friends he apparently just hung with
this big group of guys and girls and had
tons of female friends and did exactly
what you said we'll get back to talking
to sard in one minute but first I need
to tell you about Factor if you are too
busy this Autumn to cook but still want
to make sure that you're eating well
factor is the solution with Factor you
can skip the extra trip to the grocery
store plus all of the chopping and
prepping and cleaning up while still
getting the flavor and nutritional
quality that you need Factor is fresh
never frozen meals are ready in Just 2
minutes so all you have to do is heat
and enjoy and right now their Autumn
menu has some absolute bangers like a
cranberry peacan chicken and an apple
Dijon pork chop or if like me you're
struggling to hit your protein girls you
can try their Protein Plus meals with 30
G or more of protein per serving I
cannot tell you how big of a life hack
it is to only be 2 minutes away from a
30 g of protein meal at all times right
now you can get 50% off by heading to to
the link in the description below or
going to factor meals.com
mw50 using the code mw50 a checkout
that's factor meals.com
mw50 and mw50 a checkout female friends
for guys are like low stakes test
relationships absolutely I I growing up
all my friends were men and I still have
a a really large circle of male friends
my birthdays every year my birthday if
there's a table like this 80% of would
be my male friend is that not an Islam
thing though rather than like a friend
thing as in like why you just in as far
as I'm aware the typical Muslim family
would have like the [__] uncles are
over and all of the rest of it yeah we
do have a big male dominance in our in
our world uh technically we shouldn't
really be interacting opposite genders I
know I shouldn't be but I do I'll be
honest I
har so I do and I have a Hu and then but
the thing is what it meant is it I have
a plethora of understanding about the
male psyche that I could never get from
a textbook a lot of people will say to
me when it comes to my content online
they say you have a very unique
perspective how do you know this and I
said honestly it's because I have so
many males around me and I have an
interest in them so I'll ask loads and
loads of questions I'll understand their
relationships I meet their girlfriends
and I understand so it gives me
upto-date data about what's going on
with men and but I am I am biased
because what happens is I naturally only
know men who are confident but I don't
know what the psychology as much of the
guy that's stuck in his mom's basement
and addicted to pornography and I think
I'm learning that by how triggered they
get by certain conversations online so I
just think it like Destiny said it
definitely does give you a framework of
understanding the male brain that you
can't get through other women that would
be an unbelievably unpopular piece of
advice to give to a lot of the
manosphere to say that one of the best
things you could do would be to be
friends with women so that it's a low
stakes training ground for finding a a
partner down the line because it's kind
of common advice that you don't need any
women in your life that like all you
need is your boys what could I ever get
from a woman etc etc there was this um
massive debate did the sexual Revolution
fail that happened this week in LA and
one of my friends Louise Perry was on
one of the sides Grimes was opposite her
uh and Tim Dylan was there it was
mediated by Barry Weiss and um Rob
Henderson one of my friends tweeted this
earlier on it's amazing says there's
lots of discussion at the sexual
Revolution debate about whether the
revolution failed men or failed women or
helped men more than women or helped
women more than men nobody asked whether
the sexual Revolution failed children
people already know it's too depressing
of a topic yeah absolutely accurate it
basically failed both genders but when
you fail both genders you fail children
because they're the remnants of two
broken people so I think uh it's
massively failed children but I think in
some ways it's definitely favored the
man that has no desire to invest and
have responsibility that's the only man
that favors from this is he gets a bunch
of women to have low enough self-esteem
that they will be able to allow him
access without any investment meanwhile
while he's getting he can then go on to
meet the girl he actually wants to be
with whilst this girl is happy to come
at 4:00 a.m. after a night out so it's
the opposite of feminism it's allowing
men free Reign Over females and whilst
investing very very little I don't know
who tricked women into thinking that
this is beneficial but whoever did is
probably a man and then down the line
from that they've also managed to trick
women into believing that it's fine for
the guy to stay at home and play video
games and make sure that the sandwiches
are done all day you can go out and earn
the money yeah I mean it's like it's
such a Trope but people make these funny
tweets online about how the patriarchy
is so powerful at cond women into
providing for men as well yeah and the
other thing that I know I spoke about
this quite recently is the um like the
pushing the bisexuality which only again
benefits what's that I haven't heard you
talk about this well in pornography
there is a lot of emphasis on girl on
girl and there's a lot of Threes Sims
and so on and so forth and in my
personal experience seeing a lot of
straight women engage in threes Sim
activities primarily to please their um
the man but they'll convince themselves
that they like girls but they only seem
to like girls in the presence of their
partner that suggested the threesome and
they only seem to like the girl that
their partner had an insight into
selecting and then and you know it's not
true bisexuality because when their
husband or their partner is not there
they no longer have this interest in
women and also when they really care
about the guy they don't engage in the
threes and I know when they love the guy
a lot they don't want to share him but
if you were truly bisexual you wouldn't
have that jealousy because you'd be like
this is an equal playing field I also
get to touch the girl but what I think
that's happened is um the rise in kind
of experimenting sexual experimenting is
again only benefiting men I know so many
men that are in open relationships where
he can sleep with other women but she
can't sleep with other men but she can
sleep with other women who benefits from
that he get so the presumption is that
they're not actually B seual right it
does seem looking at some of the data
like women are more bisexual than men
are genuinely bisexual at least self
self-identifying outside of
relationships but yes I would I would
agree that I was surprised with this
rise of the one-sided open relationship
and in Austin there's a lot of marriages
where we're open but it's only girls and
it's only one we're
together I maybe maybe this is
I would be curious what the data would
be amongst women who've never watched
porn and their level of bisexuality I
would imagine women who have never
watched porn they B they they have lower
rates of bisexuality than women who are
addicts or watch
regularly and who are partnered with men
who also make the suggestion about
threesim I would wonder how many women
who without the external influences
because we've been taught for many many
years in the recent data that
homosexuality and bisexuality is innate
and it's something you're born with but
if the Advent of pornography increased
it then how it must have some external
forces behind it yeah well there's one
of
the legitimations for this is the
left-handedness argument and it's used
for Trans people but it might apply here
it's kind of a useful frame so I'll tell
everybody in it let me Spin A Yarn so
during the Middle Ages people who were
left-handed was seen as being touched by
the devil they were seen as being
witches right uh so it lots of people
who would have been left-handed to hide
their left-handedness they weren't their
true
selves as the world began to realize
that being left-handed wasn't associated
with being a witch or a wizard that was
relinquished and I think the percentage
went from less than five to around about
12% of the population is Left-Handed
that's they're being their true selves
yeah there is an argument made that one
of the reasons one of the justifications
for an increase in trans youths and
trans adults is that previously the
judgments of society created a glass
ceiling that made people keep it away
because they were worried about being
judged now that the Judgment has been
released I'm free to be my open and
honest self um in terms of transgender
that doesn't explain the the suicide
rate still being exactly the same
despite the world now accepting it so
there must be an underlying mental
health concern that may have then be a
precursor to the gender kind of not
identifying it in terms of bisexuality
what I would then ask is if we have now
removed the stigma from bisexuality why
are not more men saying to their wives
can we add a man to the mix can we have
it where you know you can sleep with
lots of men and I can sleep with lots of
men why is that not being seen as sexy
why that is a strange thought experiment
consider women there saying oh can your
friend come and you two do things and I
just watch that doesn't happen women are
not sitting there telling their husband
can you tell your friend to come over
and you two just do I promise I won't
get involved the way men do men are how
do you think so I think that there's
definitely an asymmetry going on here
yeah with how men see their partner
their female partner being with another
female yeah how do you think women would
perceive their male partner being with
another man there's no going back from
that for most women there once he's got
once he's for most women I'm not
speaking of all women but once they see
the man going because the the thing is
women when they provide each other with
sexual stimulation
it's nothing really a man can't do also
but when a man provides another man with
sexual stimulation women can't compete
with that it's a completely different
experience so therefore we're like you
don't like you there's nothing I can do
for you yeah you're at the wrong shop
here son you have to go back to a bit
with women I think when men are watching
Another Woman there's nothing that they
can do to each other that they he can't
really get involved in there's something
strange I I don't know why but it feels
like a one-way street that goes in
opposite directions a woman that's
bisexual every man presumes that it's
just a phase and that she'll go back
from a liquid diet onto a solid diet
eventually every man that's bisexual
yeah more men that are bisexual are
considered to just be in the closet but
have not fully committed to doing it yet
and I don't know where this comes from I
have no idea whether or not this is
actually shown up in the data there's
definitely more bisexual women and
there's more gay men yeah I know this
but I from speaking to bisexual men they
say that they if they are bisexual end
up just choosing homosexuality because I
know women don't really accept
bisexuality in them that's interesting
so it's not necessarily what they want
it's what they can get in my experience
of working with bisexual men usually the
bisexuality is not always but can be
linked to some childhood sexual abuse
with childhood and the data also
supports this and the rates of J sexual
abuse that leads to bisexuality in men
is higher than amongst um heterosexuals
so usually what happens is they may have
experienced some abuse
by somebody of the same gender now what
happens is as a result of that
experience it still creates a template
of sexual desire that they don't they
they are open to exploring as an adult
as a way of reducing the trauma when
we've been traumatized the only way that
we think we can re UNT traumatize oursel
is by voluntarily like re-traumatizing
ourselves so they end up exploring a
little bit or being a bit curious and
stuff but maybe they were actually
heterosexual but that trauma LED them
astray and if they want to go back to
being heterosexual women aren't as
accepting and so they end up some
brutal um it's a brutal situation that
you get into because you have to either
choose to be untruthful to your partner
if they ever ask about your sexual
history or agree to open up about
something that you're fearful about how
they're going to respond it's kind of
the the same as the sort of oneway
Street of doing only fans or sex work as
a woman that you are going to have to
concede that in future you're either
going to have to tell your partner and
and deal with the potential
ramifications of that or or you're going
to have to not tell them and when it's a
partner that they accepts it and knows
about it he usually with when it comes
to the only fans is a PO somebody who's
addicted to pornography and it almost
likes that but the man that's addicted
to pornography is very difficult for an
only fans woman to be with because
they're usually men who still require
novelty and still require more women and
so and so enhances the low self-esteem
for her
unfortunately there was this stat that I
put in my newsletter this week
involuntary childlessness is a male
problem too 20 5% of men over 42 do not
have children 5% more than women of the
same age group almost 40% have
experienced depression 25% feel a deep
anger there is a lot of publicity quite
rightly about women and childlessness
but men are very mute about this and
that was in the guardian oh wow um and
and I completely agree because one thing
that men online their voice online to
kind of Shame women is well you don't
have kids you don't have kids but
unfortunately who suffers more from when
not when they don't have have kids what
they find is women without kids and
without marriage earn I think about 70%
more than men that don't have marriage
and kids because marriage and kids gives
men a a purpose and meaning that they
can't derive from anything else it gives
them the motivation to work harder it
gives them the motivation to do those
hard jobs that pay more it gives them a
a will to live um with women we can
still find connections with our friends
and family and parents and we can we can
spread out our connections but if you
look at most men like if we look at your
father and like you know in that
generation without their wives they're a
bit lost I know my dad would not know
what to do with his day if my mom wasn't
around and as they age one of the things
that doctors always say the first thing
that as you as you get older and you go
go to the doctors um they'll say to have
you got a wife and even when my dad when
they do a check have you got a wife they
check because why because the rate of
healing after surgery is faster and
quicker when you have a wife and your
rate of recovery from cancer is better
when you have a wife somebody checking
in on you does a lot for a man because
they don't get that from from their
social network as much as women do so a
woman aging alone I'm not saying it's a
good thing but she's more adapted to it
than a man aging alone who then starts
to self-sabotage and actually kind of
life becomes a slow suicide for them I
had a look at Dr Robert waldinger the
guy who is currently heading the longest
ever longitudinal study of Happiness um
and marriage seems to add about four
years of Lifan to a man for a woman it's
round about the same um so men get you
know for all of the marriage is a
terrible deal for guys she's going to
take everything in the divorce don't get
me wrong you know there's a lot of
divorce and it's it's it's not great for
either party but the deal for men is
really [__] good you want to live
four years longer like find a partner
more and responsible more but one thing
I would say is that the family laws are
so horrible in certain countries and I'm
a big advocate for marriage but mainly
because I come from a spiritual or
religious background but from a
non-religious background I can see why
it seems like a death sentence to get
the law involved and to get married
because she can walk away with a lot
even if like she was up to blame so I
can understand where the fear comes from
but you almost have to take that risk in
order to get the reward of a stable
responsible life I think the risk is the
risk is increasing and the reward has
stayed the same but the risk can be
mitigated by a good selection when you
start trusting your decisions you'll be
less likely to be fearful of these
consequences but when you make poor
decisions of course everything is a risk
why do you think there's this
generalized culture of anti children and
family creation at the moment I wonder
where that's stemming from I do think
it's a sad reality I don't know where
that's coming from I just think the
reality is there's so many alternatives
to having kids now you can travel you
can really become something if you want
to become famous you can become famous
you can travel the world you can make a
lot of money you can do all of these
things but you know if you speak to
people who have even you know scored
goals in the World Cup they'll still
tell you that the best moment of their
life is when their child is born so I
think it's a really negative thing to
place um to kind of put on society I
think the reality is when you know that
you're going to have kids you have to
take more responsibility of your life
you have to save more money you have to
look after your health it gives you a
will to live now to remove that from you
is a is a slow and steady self-sabotage
when you don't have any children for the
rest of your life and you think you're
never going to have them essentially you
could be a car wreck and no one's going
to watch you whereas when you have
children it's an automatic therapy you
have to fix your traumas you have to fix
your self-sabotaging behaviors so you're
depriving yourself of reaching your full
potential when you completely write that
off I believe but I could be wrong with
that I you were preaching to the choir I
think that it's really great all of my
friends that have become fathers they've
stepped up in a way that I I'm impressed
by like they were they were hitters
before and they're even bigger hitters
now yeah which is why it surprises me
that there is this generalized anti- an
anti- family creation culture it's
really good like sometimes you know and
they even do it with men that are in
like you know uh in trouble with the law
and stuff sometimes when they have
children is the only way to get them off
the streets because it's the only thing
that gives them that Mo motivation that
they can't find outside of it so if you
are feeling that maybe it's you need to
have a kid well I I understand what you
mean as well that there is this kind
of mass
individualism um I think some of the
most common reasons is to why people
aren't getting into relationships at the
moment uh working on myself right now
just don't feel ready uh sort of Bing my
time so to speak super childish though
it's just it's a focus on the individual
um
and it's very isolationist it's very
atomized it's all about the individual
on their own and don't get me wrong you
know if you spend your time maybe you're
working working from home postco um
maybe your job doesn't actually require
you to interact interact with that many
other people or maybe you're all doing
it all through slack and through
Zoom you don't need to really leave the
house that much anymore you can door
Dash your food you can Amazon Prime
whatever it is that you need you can
stay on the couch and watch Netflix
we've become more isolated and I think
that that Trend almost causes us to
justify more
isolationism uh and it also it's called
extended adolesence a slow life strategy
that Jee Tangi found and this is just
never really getting the stage of
growing up you know young people are
getting their driver's licenses later
they're starting work later they're
moving out of the house later like the
most common living arrangement for men
under the age of 30 is still being at
home with their parents yeah and this is
one of the things I I you know I get a
lot of slack on for online because I
talk a lot about age gaps and sometimes
young women you know they go for older
men and they'll say yeah but he's 40 I
know I'm only 22 but at least he'll be
more responsible and more settle down
responsibility well maturity is not
defined by age it's defined by how much
responsibility you have and I always say
if he's got to 40 no kids no marriage
under his belt he's chosen that Peter
Pan lifestyle no 23 year- old is going
to come along and make him up he's
chosen to be that man are you sure you
want to be with him you're better off
with a 30-year-old that's got more
responsibility than a 45-year-old who
hasn't because if you think a number
defines maturity you're lost the reality
is is the amount of responsibility
particularly responsibility and care for
others so if he's supporting family if
he's supporting an ex-wife or he was
married or he had kids it does something
to men it kind of it creates a a level
of responsibility and accountability
that they can't get without that so I do
always tell women um don't be afraid of
being with a man that's had kids or a
man that's you know been married they're
better than the ones that have had no
baggage because baggage is
responsibility which is then
accountability for a man do you think
that the same is true in Reverse no
unfortunately it doesn't work the same
way with women not always it can
sometimes but it doesn't always work the
same way because a women when they have
children and good women with healthy
women actually prioritize the children
first and foremost and if she does one
of the priorities is becoming then super
cautious of the man that she allows to
enter into the man's world and her if
she's a really good mother she TRS to
keep a good co-parenting relationship
with the ex and a lot of men don't feel
comfortable with that but the true good
woman like the single mom that you
should be looking for is the one that's
got a good relationship with her
ex-husband what men do is they prefer
the woman that has no contact with the
ex and the kids have never seen the ex
and they think oh I'll go for that girl
at least the baby father is not around
that's a signal that she deprives or
prevents children from connecting with
their father that's not a good thing
that's not a green flag that's actually
a red flag so what men are doing is
sometimes they're selecting women and
thinking she's got children but she she
doesn't let the kids see their dad and
they're not in his life and he was a bum
but what does that tell you about her
selection process and what does that
tell you about her ability to co-parent
it's an insight into what would happen
if you two broke up you won't exist for
those children children that's not a
healthy mother a healthy mother is who
cheated on me he was awful he was in
wreck but the kids need their father I
drop him every Friday that's the healthy
mother but men don't interpret single
motherhood the way they should yeah do
you have any idea how
fatherlessness impacts boys and girls
behavior and what they what they look
for when they grow up and start dating
um with women they definitely here's the
problem women have when they grow up
without a father fig and they really
feel it is they'll always a lot older
men so they'll be 17 18 years old and
they're looking at the 30-y old and the
35y old and they're getting older and
older and there's a huge gap between
them now my experience of working with
women that go for these age Gap
relationships is they are in survival
mode without a father they need that
safety and comfort and the conversations
that we normally find really boring
coming from our father about mortgage
rates and like you know saving your
money they sexualize those conversation
so when they hear it from an older man
they're like oh he's so responsible it's
they're not used to it so they end up
initially going for that older man and
falling in love but once they feel safe
and they've got the money and they got
the safety they then look for men around
their own age they end up it's like it's
almost like having a safe secure base
once you've got an older Father Figure
in your life then you go on to see what
you're sexually attracted to but until
you've got that secure base you're in
survival mode you're looking for who can
make you feel safe not who can make you
feel who you're attracted to so they
confused they blur the lines between
attraction and safety and they end up
looking for it in an older man but then
cheating on him with a younger man you
think that they over
prioritize socioeconomic status in that
regard rightly so I understand why
because they don't have a backup plan
when you grow up with your father you
know at some point he'll help you and
things get rough or he'll leave
something for you and stuff and it
naturally creates a level of safety they
don't have that safety and usually they
if they come from a single mom home
she's also encouraging her to look for a
rich man because it benefits her as well
yeah there's usually some kind of like
support network okay you can come live
with us and so and so forth so they come
from a culture of you know you don't
have to love a man all men are annoying
and they're difficult so just choose one
that's going to give you a good life so
they end up focusing on social Eon
economic status but they also end up
with men with low self-esteem because a
man with high self-esteem at 40 years
old would recognize he's got nothing in
common with a 22y old who makes Tik toks
all day he wouldn't have any
intellectual intimacy so she ends up
with an older man with low self-esteem
who when she does cheat on him will
still take her back and so on and so
forth who who pays every bill or
whatever it is she so again she ends up
with a man that she doesn't respect in
the long run but really admires
initially because he provides her with
that safety she's been craving yeah you
you told me about this book you'd been
reading to do with parental alienation
what's that well the thing is I was
looking into parental alienation only
because I see it so much going on but
one of the things um punishments women
use for a man that's been that she feels
has let her down is depriving her him of
access to the children now the problem I
see happening is with the children of
such mothers especially the men of such
mothers they go on to have very very
abusive relationships so men who grow up
with single moms who blocked access they
end up with women who are very abusive
either they're Unfaithful or they
financially abuse them or they're just
they're physically abusive they grow up
with very they end up selecting very
abusive uh women and from my observation
and from what I'm reading it looks like
what happens is when you've been
deprived of a father and you've only
heard Mom's side of the story what
happens is they put their mom on a
pedestal they think Mom's women are the
innocent victims of harsh men so what
will happen is they pray to women that
needs saving they always gravitate
towards women that they can save and
help and nurture and say oh yeah that
man was terrible i've got you I'm going
to help you I'm going to show you what
life looks like because I've been doing
that to Mom my whole life the problem
with those women is they are broken
Beyond you you can't fix them most women
can't be saved they they have't
something broken that they need to fix
up themselves but the man that thinks he
can save her is the one that's a little
bit more delusional and he gets his
self-esteem from seeing her now love him
so unfortunately he ends up going for
very broken women that end up re abusing
him and he he ends up not having those
boundaries that he needs with women so
they end up in very poor relationships
when they've been raised by a mother
that blocks access to fathers you often
hear about the reverse
about women who look for the guy that's
broken but I can fix him and I can hold
on why do you think that happens we we
hear it a lot with women it happens in
men as well we hear it a lot in women
because it's a huge ego boost knowing
that a man used to be a player but for
you he changed or he used to be in and
out of jail but for you he changed
here's the reality you're competing with
people's childhood not other women if
I've got a man that's really broken and
he sleeps around and he's doing drugs or
whatever it is and I think I'm going to
fix him and I'm going to be the special
person I'm competing with his childhood
traumas you can't compete with
somebody's childhood essentially you're
always going to lose now whatever caused
that addictive behavior or that abusive
Behavior still exists before you you are
not the therapist and you are not the
cause of the wound so don't take on that
role you're only going to hurt yourself
the best thing you can do is support
them while they heal it but to attribute
his healing to you as a person is a form
of narcissism you're wanting to feel
good by his healing not for the sake of
him healing but for you to get an ego
boost to know that you could do it and
it's not the way to do it
I was looking at a bunch of headlines
that had come out recently to do with
reality TV dating
shows what do you think are the lessons
that young people are taking about love
given how many reality TV shows are to
do with coupling up and breaking up and
making up it's about winning yeah it's
all about competition essentially what
we've done is taken love and turned it
into a game show now there's no way that
won't have a chck or down effect on
society what we're learning is is to
cheat on them before they can cheat on
you get to caser more and couple up
before they can do it themselves so
essentially we're going into
relationships we're treating our
partners as opponents and who can win
and the prize of this kind of
competition is who can be the lonliest
fastest who can create the loneliest
lonely relationship faster who can get
single faster so if I cheat on you first
or if I don't text back vers or if I
don't I win but what are you winning
what's the trophy of these games the
trophy is a lifetime of loneliness so
essentially we've made the prize depress
depression is the prize of depriving
yourself of Love unfortunately I mean
you've got experience in that did you
find that it became a competition while
you in there so I was pretty bored for
most of my of all of my experience on
love Island I was also going through an
existential crisis because I was faced
with a bunch of people that I thought I
was right I was adamant that I was this
big name on campus party boy and then I
go on love Island and I'm faced with
people who are the role that I was
pretending to be yeah and I'd just read
Paulo quo's The Alchemist as well it
like the first book I'd read in probably
a decade um so I was kind of in this
weird out I had this weird outof body
experience for a good chunk of that time
where all of these things were going on
and there was story lines or whatever
and and all I was thinking about was
this guy if anyone's not read The
Alchemist by poo coo there's
this young Shepherd boy going on a
journey of self-discovery trying to find
out who he is and that really really
spoke to me at the time and I was in the
south coast of muor which is Spain and
it was in the middle of summer and I was
I read this book during the media
lockdown week and then went in in this
total [__] fever dream um so my
experience of Love Island I don't think
is perfectly representative yeah some of
the things that I did realize were that
it teaches young
people that love is a game to be played
yeah that loyalty
is both super important and also
unbelievably disposable at the same time
like think about when love Island comes
on TV in the UK I'm teamed such and such
right like cardia or whatever like
likeis like you know like whatever way
yeah they they try and do that thing I'm
team this and then as soon as one person
decides they're going to move on
typically if it's a guy he's being
totally unfair if it's a girl maybe that
dude was a bummer if he was cute or like
sweet then that was her fault and she
shouldn't have done it it's so it it it
encourages people to make very quick
decisions to fall very hard very fast to
have loyalty but only kind of have
loyalty to someone who's likable yeah
like a lot of people unlikable people
deserve relationships too you know what
I mean like it's everybody needs
somebody um yeah it's it really does
it's like a popularity contest even in
there absolutely yeah of course of
course because you know did you get real
emotions like real jealousy and real
anger or I didn't have a single romantic
emotion during love Island but I had a
lot of bromance no romance but a lot of
bromance right while I was in there I
cried when I left because I was missing
my boys like I didn't want to leave my
boys behind and i' had this really
intense emotional experience I'd you
know spent a lot of time I'd really
connected with guys while I was there
but I I the girls were perfectly
pleasant but I wasn't
that affect your self-esteem in any way
that it wasn't connecting with the girls
or not really did you just find Val
particularly I just wasn't I really was
not attracted to any of them okay so it
was we kept on
saying when the girls were coming in
everybody had a type right and I I I
don't think that they'd read necessarily
all of the guys sheets and you can see
that in the fact that there isn't a
single relationship from That season
that's still one no one no even the
winners even the winners no W the
winners last like less time than anybody
else okay um So Married at First Sight
have you seen this story I I am I'm a
familiar with it okay so for the people
that don't know the transgender bride
set to take Married at First Sight UK by
storm transitioned age 21 at an NHS
hospital before spending £50,000 on
cosmetic surgery to be taken seriously
as a woman mail online can reveal today
Channel 4 viewers will see Ella Morgan
29 who was born Evan Morgan wed a male
contestant and made a row over whether
the groom was told first or not Miss
Morgan is shown in the trailer for
Married at First Sight telling her new
husband her big secret after they
married having admitted her transition
has made her fear rejection after being
treated as a dirty secret in the past
however Channel 4 has now revealed that
they did tell the man in advance he
would be marrying a transwoman it is
understood that the man is furious with
how the broadcaster treated him during
the show and afterward but the beauty
and fashion consultant from Bristol says
she is determined to be the star of the
show to shed light on the struggles and
realities of being trans added we're not
freaks or mentally ill I'm still just
like any other
girl okay going to be difficult for you
to comment on this one son it is going
to be difficult I'm trying to see how I
can behave and not offend but here
here's the reality of it if I was even
if I was born a woman or whatever and I
had millions of Cosmetics procedures and
I have a higher risk of uh depression
because of the you know the lifestyle
I've chosen uh a man has every right to
know them and has every right to say
it's not for me it's not for me I
wouldn't be with a somebody who has born
a woman because it's just not for me I'm
a heterosexual woman and I'm entitled to
identify as that now um what I find the
thing is if it's really painful to be
transgender and it's a lot of suffering
I don't think it's good for TV to kind
of capitalize on that for views and and
use that as somebody suffering as a form
of views but I also say that it does it
does make you different from other women
if you're saying the trans struggle it
was really hard for you in your
childhood and you found it really
depressing that makes you different to
to the woman that grew up in the body
she identifies with so to say that
you're on par with the typical woman is
not true because you've gone through a
different type of trauma that we haven't
so essentially you're never going to be
like a a woman not even just physically
but also psychologically you're never
going to be like a woman and it's okay
to never be like a woman it's okay we
the thing that I find difficult to
understand about the whole trans debate
is one for many decades we were told
gender is a social construct it's just
this imaginary thing that we're telling
people we've only been told that for
about one decade yeah we've been told
it's a a social construct everybody's
saying it's a social construct the
Liberals are saying it's a social
construct but then if you say that you
identify as the opposite gender they
give you biological treatment now if
it's a social construct essentially
you're only identifying as a social
construct you don't need to change your
biology it doesn't make any sense it's
like saying that your uh football team
who you support is a social construct I
don't need to change my biology to be a
man united supporter because essentially
it's a social construct so if gender is
a social construct why do we
need to transition I think the the
argument on the other side of the fence
would be I want my outer appearance to
reflect my inner experience then why not
change your inner experience rather than
your outer don't know whether they have
control of that but that's no different
to like for example anorexic will
genuinely believe that they are the
fattest person in the world they
identify as fat now the reality is I'm
not going to give them a lipos suction
so that their brain and their body are
aligned I have to look at the
psychological defect that caused them to
be unaligned and focus on the psychology
first and if that doesn't work then we
can look at biological procedures but
the reality is I don't see how when it
comes to anorexic I get that there's you
know self it's not healthy or whatever
it is but at the same time we know the
suicide rates and transgender is not
healthy either we're doing them a
disservice by simply giving them a
shortcut to biological procedures while
skipping psychological interventions
yeah there's I had uh Hannah bars on the
show she did a big investigation into
gids the gender
identity something service that was at
the Tavistock clinic in the UK that's
recently been shut down and then kind of
restarted again and then the restart
kind of I think had some controversy as
well and um there is an unbelievably
high percentage of autism and OCD and
other sort of co- Psychopathology type
things uh in the trans community and
there is this big question that she
asked which was are people
mentally disturbed because they're trans
or are they trans because they're
mentally Disturbed yeah and there is a a
question to be ask that if untreated
autism or OT OCD or something like that
if that ended up getting treated whether
the gender dysphoria Downstream from
that would dissipate and that's a I
think that that would
encounter in some of the real like
Hardline trans communities I think that
would encounter some challenges because
they would say that almost by getting
rid of the autism you're denying the
personhood of the transperson because it
delegitimizes the gender dysphoria and
almost makes it like how the light bulbs
in here give off light but also heat
it's like oh the gender dysphoria was a
side effect of autism and we don't know
we don't know the direction of of
causality here but it's one of the most
heavily contested highly Hot Topics
would you be uh ostracized as like a a
man that chooses not to be with a
transgender woman in America
depends what you're talking about I mean
this discussion of are you allowed to
have your own preferences is fascinating
right you know if you prefer blonds is
that somehow prejudiced against
brunettes and gingers yeah if you prefer
tall girls is that somehow prejudice
against petite girls like the the line
between the question of are you are you
being either transphobic or homophobic
by not dating somebody who who is
biologically the same sex as you but has
transitioned it it seems like a slippery
slope from there to just why shouldn't
you date somebody that's self idas as
that you know I don't need to do the
external comparison do you know Blair
white you familiar with her yeah so
Blair's a good friend I she looks more
like a girl than a lot of girls do right
but I don't know I if she was to get
into a relationship with somebody and
not open up about she hasn't had bottom
surgery so it's a surprise it's waiting
to visit you at some point yeah it's a
fascinating discussion I do think that
the not
dating
transitioned
people is transphobic argument has kind
of been and gone anybody that genuinely
looks at that and says yeah you should
date how we tell you to date is it's
again like does that mean that I have to
date everybody why do I not have to be
attracted to my video guy like do you
know what I mean like I'm supposed to
I'm allowed to have preferences and yeah
it becomes kind of a self-defeating do
did you ever hear about the study with
Dr money and the twins um so there was
two twins that went to hospital to get
circumcised but they accidentally burnt
the penis off one so what the doctors
decided to do is raise a child they were
both boys but raise a child that had his
penis burnt off as a woman as a girl so
for the first seven years of life they
just put her in dresses made her believe
that she was a girl everything was like
you're just a girl but as um the girl
hit puberty she felt more and more like
a boy and she she remembering being
suicidal saying I want to be a boy I
feel like a boy I want to play with like
the balls and I want to play sports and
So eventually they told him the truth
and he went back to being a boy because
he just the self-discovery of your
hormones but eventually ended up
committing suicide because of the trauma
so the whole idea of playing with
people's uh gender especially when they
do pre-puberty because that study showed
that as soon as puberty hit in
completely a boy again so if you try and
block uh try like U pu like the hormones
before puberty you're blocking them
their self-discovery that might occur
after hormones so it's quite a dangerous
thing to do it's dangerous yeah talking
about dangerous things do you think that
hot girls are more crazy always do you
think hot girls are more crazy in your
own experience as well I've been around
quite a few hot girls but some of them
can be very balanced but I give me your
treaties on hot girls being crazy here's
what it is with a very attractive women
they don't get an insight into the
average man and how average men behave
they get an insight into men that are
incredibly intimidated by their beauty
or incredibly lustful after their beauty
so they see men either kind of ignore
them so the quiet Good Guys either just
kind of intimidated by them but the loud
gregarious kind of adulterous men are
after them so they'll see guys that will
leave their wives to be with you they'll
see guys that will uh drop everything to
kind of you know even if their
girlfriend's in the same room they're
quickly sneaking you their number
they'll see guys that will risk their
job s you know if they're your boss to
be with you so they see men as these
huge Risk Takers that will do anything
to have sex with you so what ends up
happening is she loses her naivity about
a man she no longer thinks men are
faithful she's seen so many men break up
whatever they have just to be with you
and just to access you she's seen so
many men who break their back just to
touch you so what happens is when her
husband now says to her oh I'm just
there's a new colleague at work her
brain is like well every colleague at my
work is always hit on me are you hitting
on this girl or if if her husband says
I'm just going to the gym she's like
well whenever I go to the gym somebody
hits on me what are you doing so they
end up being suspicious because they are
privy to men at they're worse when
they're sexually attracted to a woman
they don't have that naivity that a more
plain woman would have where she could
walk past a guy in a bikini and he
doesn't harass her she knows if she
walks past a guy in a bikini drops
everything so she sees men as more
dangerous than they are and therefore
she thinks her partner is more sexual
than he might be and as a result she
tends to be more intense and crazy and
less naive
not necessar more accusatory I would say
yeah because she uses her experience
about the world to predict what
everybody else's experience is about the
world and in her defense beautiful women
also it takes a certain level of
confidence and a certain level of no
fear rejection to access a beautiful
girl so her pool of men tend to be the
men that are more likely to be
unfaithful wow that's interesting so
very attractive women are a selection
effect for the kinds of experiences they
have in life the kinds of interactions
that they have with other women and
other men so presumably they'll often
see other women as threats well they
well they've experienced other women
seeing them as threats and they've seen
the competitive nature of women and
they've seen women because here's the
thing with beautiful women if you walk
into a room with a really beautiful
women all the other beautiful women
would now start looking at you thinking
well there must be something about I'm
sure they look at you anyway but they
would pay more attention because there
must be something about Chris cuz she's
unbelievable so what ends up happening
is beautiful women start to see how
disrespectful what other women can be
they're looking at your man they're
they're competing with you because to
get a beautiful woman's man makes the
other woman feel more attractive if you
walk in with an absolutely 12 out of 10
and then you give me attention I now
think I'm prettier than her so therefore
I want your attention more than the guy
that's with the girl that's not that
attractive so we see this competitive
nature of women we see that we can put
men women can put men on the map and
they see that men are very soft and they
give into Beauty quite quickly and
easily so they lead to a trust issue
that is harder to kind of overcome so
interesting the psychology of an
attractive woman is one that is very
different to a psychology of a less
attractive woman they're two different
species yeah so you have women seeing
other women primarily as enemies they're
often going to be Frosty to them U
they're also kind of hyper aware of the
power that they can bestow on the
partner that they're with which probably
makes them a little bit tentative about
giving that man that power because if
they pre-select that particular type of
man you're putting him on the map yep
and then you also said that these
women being super attractive selects for
a very specific type of guy that is
sufficiently confident to go up and
speak to you or men will make ridiculous
and wild u-turns in their life in an
attempt to get to you which also gives
you a pretty
unrepresentative experience of what most
men are like yeah and and then when the
look start to fade it's it's a harder
transition for them when the look start
to fade from a woman who is quite plain
she sees it as life when the look start
to fade um with an attractive woman she
sees it as disastrous because a lot of
the power has gone so they might not
always but they they might respond to it
with a lot more insecurity especially
after children but if she has good
values she recognizes that though the
looks are replaced with family
connection but she doesn't have good
values and her identity is built on her
appearance you'll see that she'll go
through more and more extents to kind of
um prove her attractiveness and that
might lead to promiscuity so her
identity can't be designed and around
her looks it will make her very fragile
it's rough being an attractive woman
must be hard like genuinely it must be
very difficult to try and go through the
world because with men
typically their value to the world
doesn't wax and Wayne in quite the same
way you know it starts off low even
super attractive guys will remain being
attractive for a very long time forever
like and you just have this sort of slow
and steady increase presumably and then
it'll dip out and then it'll start to
even afterwards and when it dips you
don't care it dips by that time you're
so settled in life you don't care but
for women it can dip a lot earlier and
um there's a lot of talk about pretty
privilege and pretty privilege this and
pretty privilege that but there's lots
of disadvantages and the main thing is
people look for your flaws a lot more
what happens when you're not attractive
is people can accept what you're saying
and do doing and they don't really delve
into it but when you're attractive
there's an element of other women or
even men saying well I bet she's dumb
well I bet she's a ho or I bet they're
looking for the negative so much more
and then all they say I bet she's really
arrogant and very vain so you almost
have to work against people's negative
assumptions of your character as much as
they make positive assumptions of your
appearance they make lots of negative
assumptions about your character so
you're in a bit of a battle and then
it's not as easy as it might look to
other people I saw what I was a model
for a decade and a half in the UK and I
saw a lot of the girls almost counter
signal they would turn up in the most
slouchy clothes that they could um you
know they would purposefully wear their
hair up they would purposefully wear
glasses um they wouldn't wear revealing
clothes they would uh try and act in
ways that were um more bookish sometimes
as well and this could just be their
personality it could have been the girls
that I was around but also think there
might be something going on here that
they're trying to counter signal I am
more than just what I'm currently being
paid for as a part of my career I'm more
than just a pretty face I'm more than
just a lingerie model I'm more than just
someone that's supposed to smile and
giggle and look nice on camera and is it
hard for men to realize that they more
than that or is it hard for them to like
do they can they compartmentalize and
think that she's got more to question or
do they do they get overwhelmingly like
attached to her appearance so there's a
big difference between Beauty and
hotness and most models at least the
ones that I was working with it wasn't
sort of Glamour stuff or underwear stuff
that much it was you know like fashion
stuff it was like cutesy editorial Girl
Next Door type thing so it was probably
optimizing more for beauty than it was
for hotness okay yeah um and but
certainly when it comes to hotness it's
a [__] reality Distortion field for
men right and this is what we would say
this is the word that was coming to my
mind as you talking about this that the
reality of a a very very hot woman is
like a sphere that follows around her
just distorting all of her experiences
with women with men at restaurants
getting into nightclubs with careers
everything yeah the super hot sexy woman
gets it probably the worst because they
activate a man's short-term mating
strategies they have long-term mating
strategies with who they want to family
with and shortterm who they just want to
mate with and they activate that in uh
men so a really sexy girl will activate
a man's short-term mating strategies and
she'll also activate threats in women
now women's use your threats um when
they when they're threatened with a
woman is to go prot well suggest that
she's promiscuous so they might say to
them to the men oh yeah but she's really
promiscuous not realizing that actually
makes her more attractive to them
because they're like well I'm already
looking for a short term from M you
trying to sell her to me yeah so they
think that they're actually undermining
her by saying she's so promiscuous and
she's a [__] and she's this that and the
other but the man when his short-term
meeting strategies are activated that's
exactly what he's looking for so she
ends up with men who just want
short-term mating strategies and as a
result she starts to see men as see
disposable and therefore it can it can
be really negative for the hot woman um
it does make sense about why it would be
hard to have a normal a normal mindset
I'm aware that Anderson effect yeah it's
easy to throw shade like our hot girls
crazy like it's easy to just throw shade
at them but what this is why I I like
these kinds of conversations because it
really helps everybody to understand the
experienced psychology you know the
lived experience of somebody that's on
that side of the fence and you can say
yeah privilege the halo effect you know
she's getting in for free at nightclubs
and blah blah blah it's like yeah but
what if she's got zero female friends
what if she can't find a female friend
that doesn't see her as an enemy or an
adversary or a competitor what if every
single guy that she spends time with is
terrified to speak to her or is it's
just it's so interesting so on the other
side of the fence do you think it's more
difficult for successful or desirable
men to settle down it's only difficult
when they grew up without Val when
they've got low self-esteem for men
their success in with relationships is
very much determined by their
self-esteem women can get a shortcut
with their appearance and so on and so
forth for men their self-esteem is
either going to propel them into a great
relationship or um prevent them from any
kind of stability now if he grew up
without any validation and not knowing
if he was attractive what happens is his
self-esteem is almost um blocked at that
stage of life and then he can still be a
sucker to women and still kind of accept
the unacceptable simply because he wants
to be desired but if he has good
self-esteem and good boundaries he will
never suffer in relationships he just
won't because he knows when he's welcome
he knows when he's not accepted and when
when the relationship is not working and
he has a willingness to walk away so the
the thing is money with low self-esteem
is really really difficult it's a very
lonely path it's a lot of gold diggers
it's a lot of escorts it's a lot of
partying even that the olden age now
money with high self-esteem and um good
values is you mean it's still difficult
but you you you can create something out
of that what about successful women they
struggle they they really struggle
because essentially with successful
women here's the thing men always say oh
when women earn more they leave men but
they don't realize why there's actually
studies to show that when men are with
women that earn more than them they
produce more cortisol they're actually
more angry and stressed around her and
that obviously has a negative impact on
their testosterone so they're actually
less sexually attracted to her and so
they're meaner to her they're mean and
also they don't treat her the same way
if a man is dating a woman who know he
knows is unemployed say if he's on
£20,000 a year he'll still use whatever
he has to treat her well like you know
look after but if he's on £2,000 a year
and she's on 50,000 he use nothing to
invest in her now women don't need your
money but they do need your investment
because that's how men fall in love the
more they invest in something the more
they attach to it if they invest a lot
of money in a car they really care about
it lost a lot of money into a Bitcoin
they want to see it go up invest money
into a Woman They want to see it work
out so when they are with a woman that
earns more they invest so little so
walking away seems so easy for them and
it seems so hard for her because she's
been the one that's investing in them so
it's very difficult it's not just the
woman who's rich and now she leaves you
the man no longer adds any value that is
the main issue he doesn't use whatever
tiny resources he has on the woman like
he normally would how can people better
deal with jealousy then in relationships
it's very difficult what with when it's
activated because it comes from some
childhood trauma and stuff so when it's
activated that loneliness and that you
know rejection is activated as it may
have been as a child and it's like the
world is over when somebody's jealous
but I think in my experience of working
and even my own experience of jealousy
the only thing that helps remove
jealousy is really building an identity
outside of the relationship if jealous
people tend to place their entire
self-worth and identity on the happiness
of their partner and how attracted their
partner is to them and what their
partner is doing now the reason why
that's so fragile is because your
partner is he's fallible person who's
going to have times where they look at
somebody else they might be attracted
whatever happens their entire identity
is crushed so to remove that jealousy
you really have to create an identity
outside of the relationship which gives
you the confidence that if this
relationship is great I'm going to be in
it if it doesn't work for me it's okay I
can go somewhere else but that fear of
Letting Go and fear of that they're
going to find somebody else it means
that they're in a comp constant
competition with their partner and
they're almost terrified that their
partner is going to meet meet somebody
else but really when you build your own
identity you realize if they do meet
somebody else they're no longer the
person you loved anyway so it's okay you
almost have a Zen attitude towards it
but it's very difficult do do you ever
suffer with jousy uh not massively um
but that's that's been improved by
having uh more things occur in life that
have yeah like given me a more stable
Foundation one of the challenges I
suppose is
that if you get jealous you have two
very difficult choices one is tell your
partner that can go badly that can be
perceived in the wrong way or even if
it's perceived in the right way it can
change the way that you are perceived
and the other one is to just swallow it
yourself and deal with it on your own
which then begins to create a trend in a
relationship of keeping things from your
partner well it doesn't actually stay in
your s you think you're swallowing it
but you're then manifesting it in the
form of checking when they're online
checking who they're following checking
checking and then bursting at small
things not the real issue so when your
partner turns up late or doesn't reply
to your text then you overe exaggerate
your response because that jealousy has
been kept inside so it doesn't go
anywhere when you keep it in it stays
inside you your body keeps score of it
as they say so the reality is by
expressing it and with the right person
they'll try and help you soothe that
jealousy with some reassurance with the
wrong person they'll make you feel
stupid and pathetic maybe you are being
stupid and pathetic and they can't
handle it but they'll make you feel that
way and then the jealousy then
exaggerates and increases so it's a good
test of your compatibility if you do
explain it to your partner one of the
things I've been thinking about is is
almost like historical jealousy and this
is where the body count conversation
comes in what have you come to believe
about how much body count matters and
then how can people deal with historical
jealousy better well the thing is it's
now become a big topic of debate and men
are like oh body count body count body
count it's a big deal here's what I
really say about body count The
Testament of your body count is more
your rejection rate than how many people
you slept with now if you are let's take
somebody like you for example who's got
a big name on social media looks great
access to loads of women through the
nightclub now if your body count is
let's say if it's 10 but you've had
hundreds of girls throwing themselves at
you yours is actually still low whereas
if another guy who has no access to
women his but finally gets one or two
girls to sleep with him on paper it
might be less but his rejection rate is
so low and now instead of looking at how
much how many people people sleep with
is they look at their rejection rate now
if a girl slept with five men or 10 10
men but only five or 10 men have tried
to approach her that means every man
that tries gets access but if she's a
really attractive woman she might have
higher but her rejection rate is higher
so really look at how many people you
the your partner is rejecting rather
than just their body count because on
paper a really unattractive man who has
nothing going for him his body Count's
going to be low doesn't mean he's a
decent man it's just that he didn't have
the opportunity similarly women that are
not that nice to be around not that kind
not that pretty not that attractive hers
is going to be low doesn't mean is
virtuous it's just that she didn't have
access it's the ones that have access
but choose to be um selective that's
what you should be looking at is their
selectivity problem is you can't ask
them the number like how many rejections
have you done in your life yes you can't
that's the hard part but what you can
tell is how easily excited this person
is by the opposite gender it comes quite
natur you can tell when people are super
excited when the opposite gender pay
some attention and other people who are
totally immune to it that person that
has a Glee attached to attention is
always going to maybe not have a higher
body count because they you know might
not get access but they've got more risk
of um diversion because they they get
too much ego boost from the opposite sex
and not from other areas of their life
so I think body count really has to
depend on the the person's ability to
say no to sex it's not just how many
people they slept with but how many
people can they say no to I've never
heard this Frame before I think it's
very interesting yeah what do you think
about that do you what do you think the
body count the body count conversation
is is so skewed because the world that
we're living in now is not
representative of where it would have
been 10 years ago or 20 years ago but
the the thing that I'm most interested
in is historical jealousy you know yeah
yeah yeah so hearing stories about what
your partner used to get up to even if
it happened once right and it it's so
strange you didn't even know that they
existed you didn't know them they didn't
know you they couldn't have said no
because they were waiting for you to
come
maybe this was a onetime thing or
whatever and it triggers especially in
men it triggers such a visceral fear
right of in
inadequacy of um like jealousy but it's
strange like how can you be jealous
about a thing that happened before you
even knew who your partner was so yeah
talk me through your conception of
historical jealousy what happens with
historical jealousy as human beings in
general we prefer pain we can predict
predictable pain is almost more welcome
than well definitely more welcome than
anything unexpected now where what we do
with retroactive jealousy is we hold on
to the past as a way of predicting how
they're going to hurt us in the future
the more you anxious you are the more
you perceive threats in your environment
so what's happened with people who are
jealous of the past is essentially they
believe they have a core belief that
their partner is going to hurt them at
some stage anyway now if there's no
present day evidence for that they will
look for it in the past and use that as
a way of creating hypothesis of how they
might hurt you in the future and
therefore be mentally prepared prepared
for the sabotage now so essentially what
they're doing is preparing themselves
for the worst but they can't find
evidence so they look for the past and
it's usually because of a fear of
Abandonment that they have within
themselves and I know it's more common
in men because their fear is more
stimulated by the fear of cauri that she
might histo like evolutionary wise she
might have a child with somebody else
and pretend it's yours that fear um so
it's ingrained in them but more time
that fear is activated when there's been
some childhood abandonment what about
women what what are women worried about
uh we're worri we worry not as much
about retro we only really worry about
previous exes if there is some Financial
or emotional investment still going on
usually when there's kids so what
happens is women tend to get jealous of
the ex-wife where they've got kids and
stuff like that we get jealous of exes
that are still a priority in their
resources so we're only threatened by
women that have access to the resources
whether that's energy time or money but
if you're he's not giving them that we
are more worried about future threats
that's interesting I imagine that must
make a lot of the moving on starting a
new relationship as a guy that has got
some history you know earlier on you
mentioned if you're going to go for
somebody that's a little bit older it
maybe even in some regards a green flag
that they've been through some
relationships and got some baggage you
know from that but you also have the
jealousy inclusion of the previous
partner and potentially the previous kid
resources attention so on and so forth
so that must be a difficult situation to
naate a lot women suffer from that
they're really really so jealous of the
ex and the children and so on and so
forth and it is very difficult I can
imagine it would be horrible but one
thing that again if your husband has a
good co-parenting relationship and is a
good father it's a foresight into how
good of a partner he will be to you and
your children he prioritizes his
children is really really important now
a lot of women want a man to Prior
prioritize them over their children but
what kind of man is that a man that
prioritizes a woman over his children
what kind of man is that it's not a man
you're going to be attracted to in the
future especially when you have children
with him because that means the next
woman in his life can take that priority
you need a man that prioritizes his
children and it's try and see it as
something you're admire in him rather
than jealous of him because it's a trait
that's going to come in very handy when
you have children with him God willing
but that guy that is just all over the
place and doesn't prioritize his kids
it's only handy in the short term M
there was a
post on Instagram that I saw literally
on the car on the way here when you find
out that she's unvaxxed not a feminist
loves the Lord and despised to be a wife
mother and Homemaker and it's Joe Rogan
in the video going oh like it's a a
comedy thing and the caption was do such
unicorns still exist in the comments
people were dating so girls were
replying and saying you know you should
come to church on a Sunday we still
exist out there like blah blah blah blah
blah blah but what I'm fascinated by is
what is going on where unvax not a
feminist loves the law despised to be a
wife mother and Homemaker
is like counterculture finding a bar of
gold hidden in the sand like treasure uh
it is because we're so distracted by the
women that aren't the reality is that
we're so um bombarded with images of the
women who are the opposite who are the
feminists who are out there who are not
really of the Lord and don't aspire to
that we see they're the loudest so we
see them on social media they might be
the ones that sexualize themselves a lot
more they might be the ones that put
themselves out there so what men are
gravitating towards visually is going to
be that filter of that kind of woman the
opposite and the ones that are that
they're ignoring visually tend to have
those qualities so here's the thing in
life everything comes at a compromise
now if you want somebody that will
stimulate you the most sexually she's
not going to be a virgin she's not going
to be on church on Wednesdays she's just
not going to be that girl she might be
somebody who's a little bit more uh
conventional um if you want somebody who
is going to be those you might have to
compromise now what's happening is
because we've become so shallow and we
value so many junk values such as so
many superficial things like looks when
she's not beautiful you don't even pay
attention to her so if she's not the
most stunning girl it doesn't matter if
she's what qualities have she becomes
invisible a bit like with men if they're
not tall a lot of women will ignore
their existence even if they've got all
the other great traits similarly if
she's not absolutely sexy is what men
are now attracted to they're looking for
sexy more than ever before because it's
normalized it's Instagram it's
pornography um if she's not sexy they
don't even notice that woman so that's
why they think women like this are
unicorns but they are there you just
don't notice them because they don't
have their boobs on your for you page
why do you think infidelity occurs most
commonly in your experience um I I would
honestly say if you ever get cheated on
I always I know people hate me for this
but it's usually your fault and the
reason I say that particularly with men
uh a cheating woman shows you every red
flag from day one if you choose to
ignore red flags you'll pay the price in
life you pay prices there's price taags
now everybody shows you that their
cheaters show you they're going to be a
cheat and how they show it is very
simple their values they'll maybe
they'll show you that they've done it in
the past maybe they show you that they
are not so traditional maybe they show
you that they are don't believe in
monogamy maybe they're addicted to
pornography cheaters show you their
their past they show you everything now
if you don't want to get cheated on you
either choose that cheater but know what
know what the score is and then you
don't get hurt you know what's going to
happen but ignoring red flags is always
going to get land you in that position
now whenever I have clients that I've
been cheated on a lot for five six years
A man's got another mistress or three
years she's been still been talking to
her ex I was like there's no way she can
get to three years without your you
consenting and they're like what do you
mean by that I was like they would have
been late replies there would have been
days their phones are off there would
have been not telling you where they're
going they tell you everything their
social media would have suggested
something you would have been
questioning them sometimes and they
would have got defensive rather than
reassuring you they would have been
signs you chose to ignore them the price
you pay for that unfortunately is
infidelity so you either accept an
Unfaithful and know what they're doing
and then just decide okay I can accept
it but I'd rather be with you than not
without you but you but denying the red
flags is always it's going to catch up
on you the infidelity is going to occur
so that's why people get cheated on why
people choose to do it is because they
can get the comfort of a relationship
with the joy and pleasure of a an
alternative connection so they get two
in one so they might get the comfort of
somebody who pays her bills but the sex
life of a young personal trainer that
she wants and he might get the comfort
of a good wife but then the sexual
experience of a escort when he goes and
does that so they we become so greedy we
don't realize that some things have to
involve a s a sacrifice a healthy
marriage has to involve sacrificing the
Alternatives we don't see the need to
sacrifice Alternatives because now we
are so gluttonous even if we eat a lot
we can still do that and get surgery
even if we spend a lot we can still get
credit cards we no longer see the
sacrifice of Alternatives is required in
order for positive outcomes yeah there's
a a cool quote that says
uh there are
no there are no options only tradeoffs
right that for every that you want there
is something else that you need to give
up and I think that's a good way to look
at relationships yeah if you want a good
healthy marriage unfortunately you might
have to sacrifice the most exciting
sexual experience every day of your life
because that's what 20 years of marriage
doesn't look like you know it's
realistic and if you want like a single
life then you have to accept that you're
emotional like you might suffer from
anxiety and depression in the long run
so you've got to realize whatever
decision you make it comes with a lot of
pain and suffering pick your pain being
married the pain might involve being
bored it might not being sexually
stimulated but being single the pain
might involve a lot of loneliness
depression and sadness just pick which
pain you can handle and confine yourself
to that decision and ward off all the
Alternatives what do you think about
getting back together after infidelity
um get back together absolutely you I
don't ESP if there's children I don't
say no way no way no way if there's no
children I always tell people to
reconsider um but one thing I would say
it's different from men and women when a
man forgives a female
she can't respect you the same way you
got to remember we like Alpha men Alpha
men don't accept promiscuity so what
happens when you accept a woman back a
part of her will always feel like you're
weak and you don't have the willingness
to walk away because there's nothing
that can push a man to walk away more
than infidelity and if that didn't do it
nothing will so now she's Lawless for a
man again I don't re massively
recommended unless there's children but
I would focus more on what was the
meaning behind the affair what were they
seeking and if it's something that you
can do in your marriage by all means do
it but if it's something that's more
traumatic and it's more to do with an
emptiness and a trauma in their
childhood and you can't feel that void
then you still can get back with them
but expect the behavior to continue when
I when people get back together after
fair I just say but ask yourself if he
stayed exactly the same and still
cheated 5 years down the line could you
be okay with it and if you decide you
know what I can as long as you're good
to me and good to the kids I can do it
by all means do it but don't go back
together expecting it to be completely
different it's not it's not realistic
interesting to think that one of the
considerations that you're focusing on
to do with infidelity is not whether the
person can accept that themselves it's
whether the other person can accept
being accepted especially for women yes
so essentially can you accept worst case
scenario if worst case scenario happens
again can you accept it if the answer is
no then you're just delaying the divorce
just do it now if the answer is yeah
because the alternative I just don't
want to do it then go ahead but always
ask yourself can I accept worst case
scenario then if that happens at least
you're prepared for it if it doesn't
happen at least your marriage stands a
shot it's a brutal realization I guess
for guys that maybe their partner may
have had
infidelity and then they can try and do
the work to be able to accept them again
but that is creating a rhythm A vibe
that may make it difficult for the
partner that cheated on them to accept
them back again yeah something dies in
us when you accept the unacceptable
because your masculinity is depleted and
the other thing is the man loses his
masculinity he starts to hate himself
for not being able to walk away instead
of having a pride of attached to like
okay I've kept my family together they
know they shouldn't do it there
something speaks to them so they end up
hating themselves and because they can't
always express that that they can get
quite hostile and violent towards a
woman and can get quite verbally abusive
towards her and I'm not saying she's
like an angel but the verbal Abus it's
all you're doing is like I said you're
just
essentially punishing her for your
inability to walk away she's going to
beg and say please forgive me please
forgive me but the reality is um we
don't want the man That Forgives us we
really don't we want the man that says
you had your chance it's been a pleasure
I wish you the best because that's a man
we
respect why do married women cheat um a
lot of married women a couple of reasons
they didn't marry the person they truly
wanted to marry they the a biological
clock hit them and they married who was
available at the time and they might
have had an ex that they idolized they
might have had something else that they
didn't marry correctly they didn't
choose the person that they wanted to
marry they chose the person who wanted
to marry them and so they settled to
begin with so they started wrong and
that can happen on the alternative side
it could be is when she hasn't felt
desired for a really long time and she
puts the feeling of needing to feel
desired and sexy and attractive as a
number one like uh emotion so she'll put
that over and above her family and she
craves that so if she's naturally born
like quite attention seeking or if she
married who who wanted to marry her
rather than who she truly wanted to
marry unfortunately she's more prone to
cheating yeah and and you and also if
she grew up with a bit of Chaos I find
that women that come from single parent
homes are far more likely to cheat and
the reason I I've noticed that and the
the only hypothesis I can think of is
that usually when somebody isn't
fulfilling our needs we can go back to a
safe haven of two we we're designed to
have two parents that love us we got Mom
and Dad two people love us that's how it
should be now when those two people one
of them is absent you always feel like
there's a void so when you're in a
relationship and all of it is on him if
he stops giving you that love you almost
seek it as a backup because you don't
want that emptiness that you may have
experienced as a child so they almost
have a backup before they can leave the
guy they can't just leave and be by
themselves cuz that really feels lonely
they'd rather leave when they've got
somebody else it's like having that
extra parent in your life you you like
when you have Mom that an nois you
you've always got dad you've got a
backup but when you didn't grow up with
that that being by yourself is really
horrible and Lonesome so they always if
one person lets them down they always
try and keep a back up in case that
person removes their love from them it's
a safety hatch safety hatch yeah what
about men why do men cheat um men
usually cheat when they're chasing an
ego boost they're not usually in love
with the person that they're cheating
with but they are in love with the
feeling that person gives them and
sometimes the person makes them feel
seen sometimes the person makes them
feel like theyve fed sometimes feel
person makes them feel attractive
whatever it is heard um they're chasing
a particular feeling that they are
deprived of either from their marriage
or from their childhood and as a result
they seek it it's not sexual people
think it's just oh they men love sex men
love sex there's some men out there if
they really love sex they would just
have sex with their wife they haven't
had sex with their wives in a long time
but they crave novelty or they crave
somebody else making them feel a certain
way so I don't think it's all sexual I
think it's far more psychological and
emotional than they think it is and they
label it as sex but really it's the new
person is get making them feel seen and
maybe they felt unseen for a really long
time at
home and I suppose that a lot of single
people or escorts are purposefully
portraying a version of themselves that
makes that person feel
yeah the escorts know exactly what
they're doing same with sugar babies
they know that with this man who's been
married for so long they target married
men because they have a in my experience
of what watching them what they do is
they have a leverage because every time
he doesn't pay her he can say I'm going
to tell your wife so they really do
Target married men because they've got
that leverage but also the the low
self-esteem in married men is so easy to
manipulate them giving them a phone call
to tell them that they look great tell
them that they smell great telling that
there's coffee ready they haven't heard
these phrases in a really long time and
that works perfectly with married men
but it doesn't work so much with a man
who's been on the single scene for so
long and has four or five different
girls coming over every month or
whatever it is so because everybody's
foring over him in the same way yeah so
you don't stand out to that guy how much
do you think he can change your partner
you know we've spoken a lot today about
how things that have maybe happened in
their past the way that they see
relationships the frame that they place
around this maybe it's things from
childhood maybe it's the way that their
past relationship or their past partner
treated or mistreated them mhm what have
you come to believe about how much you
can shift and change who your partner is
I think you can provide them with some
level of safety and that level of safety
can make them a better version of
themselves but what we really have to
ask yourself is why are you selecting
people you have to change the reality is
you have to se select people and accept
them rather than expect them to change
and if you can be with somebody that you
expect if they stayed exactly the same
forever would work by all means go ahead
but if you if you feel like you have to
change them you have to then change your
expectations instead of changing them
just manage your expectations expect
them to behave this way and if they
change brilliant if they don't change no
worries but expecting to change somebody
is setting yourself up for failure
because you're by default entering a
relationship that you know requires work
rather than just creating
consistency I looked at this thing
earlier on talking about I guess the
challenges that guys have of of finding
female connection especially the incel
sort of black pill part of the world
dream gf. a so I read this I read this
article earlier on it's fascinating
apparently ads for AI girlfriends have
been all over Tik Tok Instagram and
Facebook lately replica an AI chatbot
originally offering mental health help
and emotional support now runs ads for
spicy selfies and hot roleplay Eva AI
invites users to create their dream
companion while dream girlfriend
promises a girl that exceeds your
wildest desires the app intimate even
offers hyperrealistic voice calls with
your virtual partner this may seem Niche
and weird but it's a fast growing Market
all kinds of startups are releasing
romantic chat Bots available of having
explicit conversations and sending
sexual photos meanwhile replica alone
has been downloaded more than 20 million
times and just one Snapchat influencer
Karen margerie makes $100,000 a week by
charging users $1 a minute to chat with
the AI version of herself but it isn't
just unrealistic beauty standards that
worry me what's more Sinister is the
unrealistic emotional standards set by
these apps Eva AI for example not only
lets you choose the perfect face and
body but customize the perfect
personality offering options like hot
funny bold shy modest considerate and
smart strict rational create a
girlfriend who is Judgment free who lets
you hang out with your buddies without
drama who laughs at all of your jokes
control it all the way you want promises
Eva AI design a girl who is always on
your side says replica how can we
compete with that this article is
written by a woman already women in
relationships complain about about porn
addicted Partners who aren't satisfied
with actual intimacy now we're facing a
future where guys could get addicted to
emotional validation elsewhere sneaking
away for some of that unparalleled
devotion wor what about young boys who
grow up with this whose first sexual
experience is chatting with AI women who
never say no never argue never have
original thoughts or an identity of
their own and then they try to date a
real girl there's already all of these
men on Reddit raving about how their AI
girlfriends never argue complain or get
bored of them while real girls
continually disappoint point if AI
girlfriends really do become as
pervasive as online porn what will this
mean for girls and young women who feel
that they need to compete with this I
would imagine it's no different to the
mindset of a rapist essentially what
you're doing is dehumanizing the
connection of sex it's you're removing
the human component and replacing it
with uh compliancy now the mindset
behind that is very similar to a rapist
essentially you don't care about the
emotions of the person or even if they
have emotions or the trauma or anything
like that you don't don't need human
human connection you just need your fix
now when we normalize stuff like this
and even pornography has done this we've
normalized men to the idea of
dehumanizing women for the sake of
sexual pleasure and so much so that we
are now creating nonhumans to have
sexual pleasure with um we are creating
a society of rapists that's essentially
what we're doing we're normalizing rape
and legalizing it but the mindset of not
having human Connection in order to get
sexual gratification is exactly the same
so I think it's just the new version of
porn I think when we first heard about
pornography maybe all the years ago when
it started people would have thought oh
my God that's the craziest thing in the
planet no way is that going to take off
um but it's now at the tip of our hands
on the phone every single day I think
this unfortunately is the sad future for
human relationships because there's so
many people looking for instant
gratification that they would rather go
down the RO of dehumanizing than
long-term gratification of creating
connection yeah I I wonder as well it
was interesting what that lady said
about
how it's an almost an unrealistic
expectation to compete with them on an
emotional level some of those things of
laughing at their jokes and being on
their side and not
arguing that doesn't seem like an
unrealistic standard to me being online
24/7 and being able to design your sort
of dream girl in terms of the way that
she looks there is a little bit of me
that thinks is that unrealistic well it
yeah is it unrealistic to laugh at his
jokes or to to be intimate with him or
to to give him compliments and praise I
I think that is definitely there like
you should expect that from your partner
your partner should be the person the
source of your compliments and praise
but the reality is uh women are hormonal
we have a monthly cycle we're not
consistent emotionally and as a result
there are times where we worship you and
there's other times where we don't want
to be around you unfortunately that's
how nature designed us I'm not saying
blaming it all on that but that's a
reality of human nature and that's a
reality of women now uh I get it's nicer
to have that consistency but it's again
but nicer and easier isn't better for
our mental health we're designed to
struggle we're designed to be like
hunting Gathering to get a girl that's
what you're designed to go bra like go
bravery hunt gather get a lion bring it
back or whatever animal and then a woman
will sleep with you now if we're now
creating a society of men where all they
have to do is download an app to that
woman you're removing masculinity and
bravery and the ability
to regulate another person's emotions
and understand her kind of behaviors
you're removing that from men so you're
removing their ability to be their full
potential and their ability to be
masculine because that's not how we're
designed it definitely creates a a kind
of self-fulfilling cycle where guys who
have had bad experiences with with women
in one form or another rejection or
they've got into relationships and
they've ended up being on the receiving
end of something that's been really bad
will Retreat and it seems like they're
now going to be able to be serviced you
know this is it would surprise me if
only fans still exists as a a business
within the space of five years because
really you know yeah what how this would
maybe very much be able to take up take
over if it can become high enough
quality so I understand the dynamic you
know this is a safer version for you in
terms of not being betrayed emotionally
etc etc
but it does create precisely the lack of
Eligibility that you already fear in
yourself right I I want to be an
eligible partner for a woman because I
haven't got that I may turn to this as
an alternative it would be very very
surprising to me if a man said I
outright from first principles want the
AI girlfriend it's usually I would have
maybe tried to get the one in the real
world haven't got it therefore I Retreat
into this so that Retreat creates the
lack of Eligibility but on the other
side of this and the reason that you
know women as quite rightly this lady
it's a really well-written article um
this lady that wrote the article makes a
great point that this is going to create
the death of eligible partners that
women are already fearful of right so
what do you think let's say that you do
have it's going to happen it's happening
right now there is going to be some men
right a non- insignificant minority at
the very least who do Retreat into this
upgraded version of Pawn yeah what do
you think the female response will be to
this because that's going to further
skew the market of eligible male
Partners what men are hoping for is that
then they'll step up and they'll say I'm
going to be that girl that laughs and
does that but the reality is what men
women mainly will do is step down and
think forget men because I can't be
bothered to do this because you know the
addiction to pornography has made a lot
of women think oh God I don't want to
sleep with men anymore they they just
want porn they they do this wild stuff
and blah blah so it it's going to have a
counterproductive impact on women you're
thinking that they're going to step up
but the reality is when we feel like the
mountain is too high we don't bother
climbing it so what women will actually
do is Retreat into there's no point
being with a man that I might as well
just stay single all my friends are
staying single I might as well be
bisexual might be lesbian whatever it is
they're not going to step up if that's
what you're thinking this is what
they're going to do they're going to
think step up for who guys that like
artificial intelligence that's not
motivating me to want to step up that's
making me think men are disgusting and
so they're less likely to become the
woman you want them to be so we're
creating a society of Insel men but
jaded
women yeah this sort of adversarial
nature between the Sexes is not good
people are retreating
into a more comfortable but less
fulfilling less
risky uh less content version of life
but it's this move away from anything
that has to do with risk is kind of the
Trend that I'm seeing you know maybe
this is Downstream from hyper
convenience maybe this is Downstream
from a quasi surveillance state where
all of your information is tracked and
held on the internet maybe this is to do
with snowplow uh parenting and
helicopter parenting maybe this you know
pick whatever it is that's caused this
to occur and it's likely to be a ton of
different things congealing together but
I don't think that it makes for
ultimately a satisfying gratifying life
M even if you have a life which is
devoid of failure and pain and challenge
that doesn't mean that it's one that's
full of pleasure and happiness and
contentment yeah exactly and comfort is
actually the killer of Joy what they
find with people who have depression
it's not that they are um got the worse
circumstances sometimes they're just too
comfortable if you take children in
Africa that have to go Walker to get
water they have no time to be depressed
because their life is so uncomfortable
that they have a purpose and they get
through it and then they get the the
dopamine of getting what they need um
too much comfort kills Joy because if I
can wake up late every single day I
forget the joy of a lion if I can eat
whatever I want all the junk food in the
world I forget what cheat meal tastes
like so Comfort is not actually going to
create any long-term happiness happiness
comes from discomfort then problem
solving that discomfort and then getting
the dopamine reward unfor so it's a bit
of a longer process sya KH ladies and
gentlemen where should people go they
want to keep up to date with what you're
doing at Saia psychology and just go on
Tik Tok I'm everywhere there
unfortunately I apologize but I seem to
be everywhere on Tik Tok at Saia
psychology what else are you doing what
can people expect from you next I um I
still have my patreon where I release
exclusive videos that are just for those
people that are looking to learn and
improve I also offer onetoone
conversations and onetoone coaching I
also reply to people on my patrons that
have quick questions so I am very
accessible and available at the moment
so I do apologize for being so saturated
because I feel like I'm getting a bit
sick of my own face but I am available
if you should need me for any Services
sorry I appreciate you thank you thank
you so much thank you for having me if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe